Hello everybody welcome it is Friday Feb
third third we are very late and I do
want to say uh-oh that Fridays are late
days and what is the equation
what is the one part of the equation on
Friday that is not on all other days of
the week
[Music]
I'm just saying what
I was ready on time I was waiting for
you what the [__] you're in the you're
always in the backyard doing all your
fat you're like a fashion blogger I I I
came back inside and I was like is Ethan
waiting for me and Elizabeth said no
he's still upstairs
in dozer no I was down and ready to go
by the way there was more traffic than
usual I was like camera in the house oh
like a game camera
for who first of all there was more
traffic than usual but on Fridays you're
out there you're like out in the garden
I enjoyed in five minutes yeah but then
it's like okay we gotta go and then
you're like okay you gotta pack up all
my lights and my video equipment and you
have big ass boots you can't walk very
fast you're making it all up right now I
am not don't put that all on me I have
like 10 minutes to do my makeup and then
five minutes to do my photos I'm very
time conscientious
and I get it done listen when I during
the normal week what am I usually late
like seven minutes
but you take your time you're like it's
Friday what I never said that I never
said that do not say I said that like oh
it's Friday baby it doesn't matter for
30 minutes late
listen
you're making [__] baby that's all I'm
gonna say okay well just I'm gonna put a
camera from now on just do the math I
mean every other day is not that bad we
got so many cameras already we just need
one more at the house
where are you gonna put it at the garage
door
to show The Kitchen you want it it
depends who's waiting for who
a where are you flying Gabe
I'm at the movie theater oh you're
saying that Avatar's a piece of [__]
[Applause]
[__] movie go watch other stuff like
hobo White Lotus and Specialty house
party the best movie ever I love white
photos wait White Lotus is a TV show
right it's a TV show yeah it's about
Italian settling in Italy experience
Italy like
have you watched about the same thing
White Lotus yeah yeah a little bit but
pretty good okay okay
not at a movie theater though right no
no that's a show yeah okay I'd say house
party house party is the best okay so
you're not going to the movies you're
just there to you think it would give
extra credibility to you saying [__]
Avatar yeah
Avatar sucks that's why they put the
poster down
oh they took the poster down no yeah
congrats bro that's all from Gabe
lobbying them well okay she's full of it
how many Oscars do you have how many
Oscars you got oh great Dan is simping
for Avatar now
that's just what I need hey Gabe
um
Dan's calling you a liar can you do a
360 on the phone and see we just need to
confirm if there's no Avatar posters
I don't see nothing right there you you
um
it's all I see right there they took it
it was there here it is a couple of
weeks ago but they took it down to put
something out
I don't see it okay can I say that Gabe
is looking flies yeah you look awesome
bro yeah hype
Essentials
Essentials oh my God look at you wait
who's which brand is that it's by fear
of God oh you feel fear of God yo what
the [__] the best friend Gabe turned
into a hype Beast my dude
nice man no you look good bro what shoes
are you wearing today
Nike okay classic Nike Nike on my shirt
um okay do me a favor are there lots of
people in line buying tickets can we see
what movies they're seeing
let's see
um pretty dead at the theater yeah not a
lot going on there yeah
who's that person what's she seeing
behind you there
I'm not sure oh it's a guy I don't want
to get choked yeah
okay that's fair he's probably seen
Avatar though if I had to get just
chances are he's probably seeing having
no other odds are good
waste your time seeing like three and a
half hours
you want something else exciting like
house party house party okay awesome
brother well I'm not I am not seeing
Avatar I pledge to you my friend all
these people in here are seeing it
they're telling me to see it Gabe but I
know who my real friends are you are our
real friend and I am not watching that
dog [__]
Blue Smurf same Blue fetish movie
I'd rather watch Smurfs which is an
anti-semitic cartoon
I would
all right Gabe
any plans this weekend
maybe have some Korean barbecue and
maybe do some cuddling
with who whoa
someone I love I guess
is this a soft launch
it's interesting somebody gave
uh I don't know yet but
you just said that you loved them though
I'm mad
okay so wait have you been on a date
with this girl or you guys have cuddled
before
um not yeah it's a plan the plan is the
plan
[Music]
wow exciting Gabe I this may be a little
bit forward and you there's no pressure
to answer it you could just tell me I
don't want to answer it I don't know if
I've asked you before are you virgin or
have you have you had sex before
I'm a virgin you are okay really be
honest yeah no that's fine I I get it
there's no shame in that wow and so is
the pl so okay well this whole hopefully
this lucky lady yeah is going to uh
get that once in a lifetime v card from
white clock Gabe huh
Valentine's Day is coming up so right
yeah yeah and so
if I can give you a recommendation
probably if you think there's a chance
you might have sex it would be wise to
to beat off before the date
I don't want to pay the price later yo
well because you which because you won't
bust fast and also it clears your head
yeah yeah so that's just a little advice
yeah and because your version maybe
maybe do it like two or three times just
for safe measure but also sure you've
got to be careful here you know take it
slow get to know her you know
you know doesn't need to happen right
away how come you're so confident you
guys are you're gonna cuddle if you
haven't even met her who is this girl
um I don't know yet okay cuddling like
okay he's manifesting the power of
positive thinking yeah yeah I don't say
you know it'll come when it's gonna come
and what I'll say
yeah now Gabe I just wish you all the
best okay well I want a cuddle update oh
here's Gabe in
this is the enemy of avatars I believe
and you see that game the way of white
claw the way of like you're you're
Manning one of these uh meccas that sick
ass mechs dude I'm wave I'm like Mecca
all the way yeah decimate their dumb
Planet they get lots of there's lots of
Mecca W's in this one
let's annihilate them Gabe let's destroy
it all right hey good luck tonight I
wanna I wanna I wanna cuddle update okay
for next yeah good luck sure
we're we're all rooting for artists
love you bud
love you all right
if you wanna spend the night get my
[__] spend the night
foreign
[Laughter]
I beat you again Gabe all right have a
good weekend Bud we have a good one
you're the best that's white Club Gabe
on Cameo he's out there and I think I
really want him to uh get laid
I just want him to cuddle
yeah
I don't know why you all think it's so
crazy that I want to like send him to
Las Vegas
when did you say you want to send them
like but for explicit purposes like
because the prostitution's legal there
um it's well regulated it's legal
you can't support be like oh support sex
workers and then say Oh Ethan's trying
to get Gay Blade I could send him to Las
Vegas I don't think it's crazy but I'm
feeling everyone acted like I was a
[__] sick but I feel like if you
wanted to he would go he seems like a
go-getter like he's always out there
doing stuff yeah he's gonna cuddle I'm
not I'm not trying to bend his arm or
anything I never even suggested it to
him because everybody freaked out was
right here from that conversation I
don't remember yeah I don't remember
well he was saying the first Insight we
had is he said he never went down on a
girl and I was like okay well I got you
we can make we you know we should we
could probably see if we can make that
happen for you but now
as I suspected he is he is a virgin and
I don't think it's a terrible you know I
want the best for him he's my boy
right I never even said
thank you
I agree thank you thank you finally
somebody [__] agrees with me God damn
thank you thank you yeah
I think we even did a poll and everyone
supported me but you know you always
compliment me
and I want to say you've been looking so
good lately really yes
this morning and I'm looking kind of fat
and uh no preview monitor but no I have
been weighing myself and I'm definitely
I've been I'm good at like stabilizing
my weight I've gotten a lot better
thank you by the way and I want to push
that I want to push to lose that other
uh 10 pounds right now I'm hovering
around two what is it is two
Twenty Eight 229 area so I gotta push
hard lose another 10.
and then we're on our way to mailing up
that day we're on our way I'm 28 pounds
to go my friend
can I if we put mayo on your Dome how
about how about this we make an egg
salad on your head I never agreed to
that Dome don't push like don't push
that's right what's the name of that
restaurant where they do all the tricks
and [__]
oh my God shrimp off the Dome Dan get
that man maybe if we get one of those
like really good Hibachi chefs that
knows what he's doing that would be
something
hey I've got an idea so we'll have a a
flat surface like the grill and then we
can have a hole with just your head
pokes out oh my God so he has more
surface to work with yeah yeah I love
that yeah that would work better we can
have a camera under the table with you
just so we can see her face all right
well if it helps motivate you then oh
thanks that's real friendship Dan really
wants me to lose weight you like
mayonnaise
I do like mayonnaise
um so yes thank you thank you I do want
to say first of all thank you to Teddy
fresh one of sponsors today Gila you
want to talk about your party I'm
sponsor you yeah thank you Queen
um so next Thursday the February
collection is coming out and
let me tell you I love so many pieces in
that collection there's a lot of stuff
for women this time
um so get ready girlies
uh this this cardigan is one of the
stuff that's coming out
and yeah that thing is nice chunky wow
it's like a perfect Gucci sweater it's
perfect and I love we made this custom
pants with like a teddy bear head that's
sick and you can even take it off and
put it on something else if you want
so I just love it I'm so excited and
also out of your league t-shirt is out
oh this is the one dedicated to actually
that one to all the guys who think I'm
ugly wait where is it right there oh
it's in white that's for me on and you
know any of any of you out there that
can relate Donnie or guys or totally
it's a unisex shirt listen I'm out of
their league too I love this song Wait
League
and it's a little bit like a tiny bit
more Slimmer fit than our regular kind
of slightly oversized made in the USA
made in USA America
we have a go go to the website check it
out there's all kinds of fun stuff all
these Classics I highly recommend yeah
they're just perfection you know what I
mean and uh the bags are awesome
so nice
and uh that's what it is thank you thank
you also I want to say something
um
Kristen said sincere appreciation and
credit to Ethan for his health Journey
okay thank you so much
I do so I have seen a lot of comments
like I'm losing weight with you I'm
losing weight that's so sweet yeah
that's nice that's really cool basically
I'm saving more than my own life
I'm not a fish Zach
there's a shark
basically
I'm a saint by losing weight right yeah
let's keep saying that every morning
annalize said I'll take Gabe's v card no
joke someone DM me
I is so like can we DM her what do you
guys think that's between Gabe and I
mean he's not pulling his arm let's just
let's say hey Gabe so let's we let's
reach out to her yeah vet her a little
bit and then say Gabe we have this
opportunity totally up to you this girl
she's ready to cuddle she's ready to
cuddle him but what about the girl
though this weekend exactly he's
recording her he's courting someone
right now it's just a plan B it's a plan
B look when people date they go on
multiple dates you know this is just
this is the research stage you know what
I mean he's ready to he's a Playboy he's
not dating one girl Dan everybody's got
their little plans
let's do a poll do you guys think we
should reach out to annalize
anal lease
God you live with that one surprisingly
do you think we should vet because I'm
shocked on a lease
I was gonna say it's such a nice name
and then you were like anal
should we vet her at four and then give
Gabe the option no pressure of course
just this is just Gabe anal sex yeah
people are saying no we see lots of no's
but that's okay that's why we're doing
the poll do not come
listen is easy to reach I'm assuming so
if she wants to she can probably get a
hold of him actually that's a really
good social media that's a really good
point he's probably he's probably very
easy to reach animals if you want to
make this happen on your own yeah they
could connect yeah probably better if we
don't intermediate that but but let's do
the poll I'm just curious how far off am
I
do you guys think we should vet annalize
for Gabe give Gabe the option no
pressure of course see that that's a
good poll
yeah you wrote it
well there's good yeah okay no 62
apparently it's a horrible idea yeah I
agree
jacket oh I mean dude okay you guys want
Gabe the Divergent that's your [__]
that's on your conscious he's not going
to this is a this is why I don't
understand he's he's dead
let's not pretend like I'm going to
isn't he like he's 50 years old
bury our head in the sand and act like
this guy he need he like if he can
actually
Dan why do you want him to diverge him I
don't I don't I don't want that for Gabe
he's 50 years old he just turned 50. the
man the man
he deserves to have that experience
thank you
thank you thank you people are
passionately against it though huge fan
Chad has lost me no fun anymore thank
you Blanco that's what I'm saying if I
can't arrange sexual
dates between two watching members then
where are we even in this world and it's
a sexual dance David dobrik Vibes I'm
not going and sneaking in there and
filming it okay and I'm definitely not
bringing alcohol for for minors
kind of pimping out your fans to oh my
God I'm not pimping out the fan she
offered
second of all I'm not filming it at all
I think I'm doing it for Gabe like we
said if she wants to she can get a hold
of him yeah that's the truth that's all
that's the truth
I just care about him so much you know
yeah I want to say uh moving on a little
bit that
uh Zach I want to say because he's
getting some residual hate from my is my
mistakes
uh not wanting to dwell on that but I do
want to say Zach is innocent
thank you clearly I mean I think I said
that it was obvious I said that in the
episode but like there's some dumb
[__] articles that I guess they just
rushed to get it out right and also some
of this hate is it's like by association
so
there's a lot of people that
are still pulling me down with it look I
I press the button I'm just doing my job
here you're just following order I'm
just doing my job here you're just
following orders right exactly yeah you
know that is a that that defense has
famously worked well uh historically
exactly some Manson [__] um so look I'm
just doing my job here I don't I'm not a
misogynist I'm not I'm not a I'm just
getting called horrible [__] well really
yeah and I'm being called a Nazi like
what well I called you a Nazi what
context does that even make sense I
don't know but you know shabbat shalom
I'm not a Nazi
um I wear star David around my neck
thank you you're not a Nazi I've been
saying we're just following orders I've
been staying off the internet pretty
much because I knew it was gonna get
yeah dirty yeah I need to start doing
that a little bit yeah you should do
that I was like
I know this episode was messy I'm just
not even gonna go anywhere on there like
reddits yeah waiters bury my head a
little bit when that happens yeah but
you know
people do take it too far like on the
internet when you [__] up in some way
yeah the reaction people have is like
um
he is a disgusting human being he's vile
he I I I've watched for 12 years and now
I'm [__] unsubbing and I I don't know
it's just like
um
there there's just a lot of you know
unwarranted [__] that I it's hard
reading about yourself you know so
um yeah
well Dextero this is a demand for uh
or uh
what do you call it
correction
um yeah they even spelled my name wrong
well then that's good because it wasn't
you right it was my mother's day it was
Lou yeah
Lou oh is Lou the good guy yeah we're
gonna find that character yeah Blue's
gone but uh Tommy said uh this talk is
exactly why I never tell anyone it's the
constant let me help you okay
wait what I guess he's saying he's also
in the Years virgin I see okay that's a
good point okay
Lindsay says Ela your makeup looks great
your confidence makes all your looks
elevated Queen also don't beat yourself
up over it there isn't anything you can
do now and we still love you I laughed
oh don't admit that
thank you Bradley Martin
that can't be really him can it no why
are people talking about Ethan and
cutest real but not talking about
Jeffrey Epstein's stuff I get it
somebody's impersonating Bradley Martin
that's a real that's what I've been
saying I mean how is anyone going to be
mad at me when those names are still
being held Secret
yeah we love you Zach
thank you and I I love you guys too and
again I was just following orders doing
my job and
let me look at history of I was just
following orders I'm sure the whole Nazi
party what was that what was that trial
that Nazis on the Nuremberg Nuremberg
let's see if that worked for them
let's see how the Nazi defense of just
following orders plays out
but that's that's that's not even a good
comparison right Zach no no I don't
think you can either you guys cast
anyone yeah yeah I was getting he was
gassing me up
um yeah but no not a Nazi not a
misogynist no he's not attacking folks
not a piece you're already here first
I can say I can vouch for Zach he is not
a Nazi yeah
as far as I can tell anyway I don't know
what you do at home right all right what
does he do in the dark oh yeah this was
a meme on the subreddit I was just
following orders
and with that this is true it's not his
fault that's something to me that that's
it I don't know who that is that guy got
in there yeah oh my God I love that
exactly
he did nothing wrong no
[Laughter]
oh Jesus
we love you Zach thank you thank you
I'll even I'll even be I'll even go a
step further and absolving Zach yeah
I told Zach play the chestnut song
and he said really question mark
question yeah with like a bunch of
questions and I said yes so like it's so
on me and not Zach he even said sir and
I said follow orders
yeah but um I think be great if dexterto
can you know revise that [__] and maybe
spell my name right you know let's get
that blue do you want the cloud or not
why do you want that cloud that's what
he's upset about he can't get the clock
because they spelled the name wrong
right but you want that kind of music no
I'm falling on the grenade might as well
get something out of it yeah I I need I
need just my name and print so you're
okay with them blaming you no no no no
no no no you didn't say maybe it's okay
that the name is wrong in this context
yeah but it's good for you yeah uh
you're you're the logic is not making
sense it's a uh if somebody brings it up
you can say that's not me it's kind of a
Sophie's Choice situation here
so is that difficult I guess but no I
don't I don't necessarily want it all
jokes aside I don't I don't want it I
just want my sins to be uh yeah it's my
fault I was in Goblin mode that whole
day and it was just it was your turn I
had no [__] I had that whole day I
just felt like not the whole day oh
after after the Rebecca Black yeah for
some reason
I was in full Goblin mode and like
sometimes I get like that I don't know
that you should go past three hours
because that was the fourth hour oh
interesting it does there's there's
something to that there's some science
there right tell me if you think I I saw
what I thought
was a fairly insightful comment on
Reddit about it which is that
with the conversation with Rebecca Black
because
um you know her story is kind of messed
up everything that happened to her and
traumatic and everything you were being
very careful in that conversation and
that
there was like a rubber band effect like
when she left you were like freed and
you went
180 in the other direction of just full
Goblin mode to be honest with you I do
think that has something to do with it I
also think that I have an impulsivity
problem with that's related to my
Tourette's which I am now discovering I
can actually use that as an excuse
look at this comment why didn't we wrap
up after the interview we still have to
get canceled exactly
[__]
I do genuinely think they're that I'm
not normal right you are normal come on
[Music]
um but why is it though
by the way and I don't like I'm not
trying to uh I'm not trying to cop out
and not accept responsibility of course
I do but I'm trying to understand maybe
there's something in me that is no I I
agree because
I know you in real life not on camera
and I know your views on things and I
know that you would have never laughed
at her crying of course of course
obviously to be honest that's why it's
like It's upsetting for me to watch you
do that to yourself because I know you
and I know that that's not you but I
know for somebody else opening the show
and seeing that what that's gonna look
like it's gonna look awful and I think
that yes there's some kind of an
impulsive thing that you sometimes
listen you gotta play with fire it's
like you just have to I do and I'll tell
you look look I love my job
I love to
make you guys laugh and explore the
medium of doing comedy in this kind of
open impromptu setting
and like
it's funny I did it so fast I almost did
it on purpose so fast that I didn't give
myself a chance to even think about it
because I was like
I feel like this will be funny I was
like I feel like this would be funny
because it's so [__] up and you only
like you only let that thought go
through before the second thought it was
like maybe it's not a good idea though
that that did not approach my brain
there was no that wasn't an option you
know and the chestnut song was just the
moment it really was the moment well I
feel like it was in my opinion it was
funny during the first half of the story
when we were talking about the um what
was the dude's name patriarch yeah
yeah but that the thing is like that guy
is obviously a douche and it's okay to
satirize him but she someone that I'm
actually like friendly with and who is
expressing herself vulnerably vulnerable
vulnerability and uh is the victim then
obviously that is not the vibe that I
want it's to make her feel bad and
actually you know what really made me
feel bad is afterwards
I talked with her and she told me that
essentially it made her feel bad and so
that I felt gutted by
and also her boyfriend reached out and
was like why and said something like to
the effect of like why are you so mean
and that made me feel horrible yeah
because obviously
that's never the intention and and um
yeah
and um
because because really at the end of the
day all that matters is how she
perceived it and she didn't like it and
he didn't like it and then then I felt
really really bad
you know what I mean
there is a touch of ableism though when
people blame me
I'm just saying I have my I already got
my handicap placard
there's some old dude trying to get in
front of the like big ass parking lot at
the movie theater I'm like
step off Grandpa
there's a there's a curb episode uh
about that where the guy has a stutter
and he's got a handicap placard and
Larry calls him out because he's not
like he doesn't have any physical
uh disabilities but he has a stutter and
he's a handicap
that's what I need I bet I could get one
if I really lied my way or just
exaggerated like I have Tourette's and I
am doing all this all the time and I'm
impulsive they'd be like all right take
the [__] placard
but you know what it's like
it's hard it's hard to completely I have
to I'm doing a lot better than I used to
in general I think
um
there's a maturity that I've I think
I've achieved a certain
maturity in terms of like when I [__] up
I don't I'm not getting defensive and
I'm like
understanding and you know confronting
what I've done
okay
but at the same time so in that part I
think I've I've
matured and you remember Dan there was
times when
uh because you've been with us so long
where I would get into [__] and I
usually got defensive and then
it would make everything worse I don't
know if you remember that stuff like
that oh I remember yeah yeah no I I
definitely agree with you uh as you were
saying that I was raising my eyebrow a
little bit about the because
just on the on the front end of getting
into the [__] in the first that's the
problem right so but I agree that the
aftermath and the acceptance of faults
and sort of the reflection part has
massively improved over the years yes
definitely grown up okay good thank you
for co-signing that so yeah and one term
and one way I have matured
but on the other time it's like I don't
want to compromise what makes this show
special to me I know what you mean I
don't want to second-guess myself all
the time and I you know what I mean and
and and and as bad as that may sound to
me the minute that I start
second guessing myself then then the
show is not going to be as good or
special and if I [__] up I apologize to
her I says I'm so sorry you know what I
mean I'm so sorry but at the same time I
can't [__] hamstring myself
I know exactly what you mean that's
coming I go to that other side of
becoming so self-aware yeah of what
everybody's gonna say gonna think how
they're gonna perceive it that I almost
like become
just not even myself or I just don't
talk or I just don't say anything
because all I hear in my head is just
the thoughts of what I'm gonna see
people saying what they're gonna think
what they're saying in the chat with all
this stuff it's like it kind of takes
over your your own thought and you're
just stuck in that mode totally and you
can't you can't do a show like that no
and I've been in place I've been in that
place before and it's just it's not it's
not a good place to be
and so like I think the important part
is when you [__] up to acknowledge it
and apologize right
and but the thing but at the same time
I got kind of be I gotta gobble about
sometimes
I gotta Goblin mode
I mean a lot of the goblin mode moments
are the funniest moments on the show
exactly so I can't you know what I mean
you can't pick and choose because the
fan there's a lot of fans who are like
you know on one hand oh it's so funny
sometimes oh he's so out of pocket it's
so funny Ethan's in Goblin mode and they
love it but then when it goes too far
and by the way my my ratio is pretty
good like I'm looking at like 20 Goblin
modes to one too far demon mode let's
call it well
maybe is different watch that demon die
well what do you call what demon mode is
like
okay all right so what mode am I in then
when I for example did that to cutie
Cinderella
Goblin gone wrong
Goblin gone wrong for sure so I don't
know you know what I mean uh so like my
ratio is pretty good so far
you know I got a call from my you my
YouTube uh rep the day after that
happened you know and I was like there's
no [__] way bro he thought it was a
strike income and he says call me back
oh [__] and I I texted I was like run
cold bad news
and he's like no I just need you to sign
the new YouTube party thing thank you
but yeah
that scared the [__] out of me we just
got back can you imagine we just got
back and we already getting [__] yeah
shit's coming out of my down my leg
so you know what I mean and there's
people so wild like in Hassan's chat
they're going like oh and you still
associate with him people were like
demanding he ends art
podcast and it's like
seriously you know like I get that it
was a super insensitive
totally wrong time and place joke like
everything was super inappropriate about
it yeah
but y'all really want to [__] just
it's like dude I don't know man people
just
people on the internet that's not how
you live your life the people saying
that like if you have a friend that
[__] up you're not like I never want to
see you again right that's not how real
life works I'm not a sex criminal I
didn't kill anybody you know what I mean
I just made a bad joke and I get that
so I don't know sometimes I question if
some of these people are even real or
they even have like a real life how can
you actually think that's how life works
you know what I mean
that's what it is
and uh it's gonna happen again and if I
go too far I'm gonna apologize and I'm
gonna reflect on it and I'm gonna try
you know
to uh work it out but there it is
today I feel disabled
[Laughter]
right on brother me too man so there it
is I don't know but I love y'all and I
feel so bad and I apologize to cutie
Cinderella who I respect and uh I wish
her all the best
thank you
Lord
this is a serious message to all victims
of goblin mode I would like to issue an
apology thank you thank you there was
one actually pretty insightful post I
thought or maybe it's not a perfect
comparison but there was like a post of
us laughing at Jay Leno in his
hyperbaric chamber his body like burned
and they're like we love this and then
it was Cutie Cinderella crying and
they're like we hate this but honestly
it's not that great of a comparison
because one I know cutie Cinderella and
two Jay Leno was literally he wasn't
saying anything he was just there like a
cadaver he wasn't there crying no he
wasn't yeah it's not a great comparison
if he was I'd probably laugh about it
though
hey Leno look you're not arguing that
the joke was not right no so we all
agree good
thank you
peace and love think peace and love all
right so um I was permanently banned on
Tick Tock guys they finally got me you
guys you may notice that my my wonderful
Tick Tock live stream
oh man and you know what are we gonna do
without that
perfect is anybody watching this right
now if they're not finding it on Tick
Tock and coming over
I've essentially been banned
yeah so when every time I would go live
almost every time I would get
uh
suspended for hate speech
or harassment because all these dumbass
tater tots come and mass report it yeah
and usually I would appeal it and then
it would be fine the next day but so
yesterday morning I tried to open my
account and it goes you're permanently
banned it won't even let me log in you
lot it's just like uh download your data
or log out and so like the feet that
feed my Tick Tock feed that I've spent
so much time curating is gone damn so I
made like a new account and it's just
dog [__] dude like mine it's just back
to the square one place
it's all like super brand friendly dumb
[__] yeah that's why I still never got
into Tick Tock because I never went past
that it's hard I didn't put into work
I'm not put I'm not ready to go through
all that again Tick Tock is not going
anywhere
so I don't even know I don't have no
anyone at Tick Tock I message their
support they said here fill out this
form this Google form I was like okay
I'm sure that's gonna help me you want
to use my account and get me Bantu
live on your account
I will definitely get you banned seems
like so probably not a good idea Twitter
2.0 but we'll see maybe apparently that
also happens to Hassan he said because
he has the same people reporting his
videos and every time you post a tick
tock it gets Mass reported and then his
V his account gets banned it's like
their systems are don't make any [__]
sense dude has he made it back ever
after this he says he he has a tick tock
wreck they went and manually unbanned
him and then the next week he got banned
again wow
because
I think there's so much content being
uploaded on Tick Tock they have these
algorithms that basically moderate 99 of
the content and it's really not good
really not good so if there's anybody in
Tick Tock world out there but basically
what I'm saying is that
I'm ready to embargo China okay this is
a Chinese company Tick Tock and if
they're gonna snap they're gonna Stomp
all over my free speech right then it's
time to draw the line all right
Taiwan is not not only part not part of
China it's part of America now
[Music]
colonize Taiwan oh wait I want but
yeah you heard matted at mainland China
are we colonizing Taiwan for what
championships it's just a stick it to
them yeah just to stick it down Taiwan
is now the 51st day eat that Winnie the
Pooh ass [__] no I mean I guess you're
right they wouldn't like that they would
hate that yeah it does
seem a little mistargeted well taiwan's
probably down why wouldn't they be when
everybody wants to be American right I
talk to them they said yes well taiwan's
scared you know they don't they don't
like all the China threats and so if we
come in and be like yo he's with us
then it's kind of a Vibe so not only
that but now I am I am officially
calling for the ban of tick tock in the
United States and it's time I hate to
say it I never wanted to go here but I'm
we're going to triller folks
we're going to triller let's get [__]
flip dude and the idea is that hopefully
we can get Kevin Hart out there yes oh
yeah so finally they didn't uh do false
advertising yeah
nobody [__] don't listen to him no we
love Thriller I'm not being clear your
clear as day my brother
but uh
I'm doing it
yeah so I don't know how else we can
stick it to China they don't like Tibet
right can we make Tibet 52
uh yeah sure Dalai Lama is one of us now
why not
you know what I mean
and I'll tell you what else we'll do I'm
gonna start my own organ farming
facility so that we can take back the
Oregon Black Market from them
they're already doing that in
Massachusetts exactly we didn't get to
that story the other day but yeah so in
Massachusetts they're trying to pass a
law where where you can prisoners can
sell their [__] organs for two months
that's all you get knock two months off
your uh off your sentence for giving a
kidney
baby that should so by the way there's
no way that's constitutional I'm pretty
sure that's
there's got to be federal law against
selling organs
I
I mean it it was just a proposed thing
it probably won't even pass because
that's [__] insane proposed by
democrats by the way seriously yep two
Democrats in Massachusetts but why two
like if I'm ready if I'm getting ready
to donate to Oregon yeah why two months
like you're gonna need to be more
compelling than that I'd rather just sit
in jail for two months at least six
months a year two years three five years
here's Dalai Lama he's ready he's on a
weeaboo actually let me pull it up
because they're uh the one of the two
people that proposed it had a tweet
about it and it was actually it was one
of the most psychotic tweets I've ever
seen actually I do want to see it yeah
foreign
yes so basically China has this they
lock up all the Muslims there the
uyghurs and uh they Farm their [__]
organs and [__]
for Chinese people so I'm taking that
back for America
let's see we're gonna Farm prisoners
organs they don't need them
great plan you got there I'm sticking it
to him
that's right
uh there it is so I don't know what to
do but if you know someone at Tick Tock
please help me
please
you know every time I would stream it
would say congratulations you're in the
top 99 of all of our streams and they're
always begging they should always
they're just going please we want people
to stream right and they're always
sending me emails like yo here's
streaming tips for our vibrant streaming
community and then what I'm number one
the top one percent
um
then I'm getting banned [__]
Hong Kong's part of America now
[__] you please I hope you have a plan I
do we're taking Taiwan we're taking Hong
Kong and we're taking Tibet and what are
you gonna do about you Winnie the Pooh
ass [__] here's the question
Ethan would you give a kidney to get
unbanned from tick tock
um that's a good question is our trade
please I say no I would not do that I
have I have wondered if it's possible to
donate my kidney to Shredder though
oh my God that's worth it I'm pretty
sure it's not going to be compatible
like my kidneys the sizes of his own
body yeah
I've thought about how small his kids
have to be in his tiny little body oh
maybe just a piece can't they just take
a piece of my kidney and
foreign
it's doing good now actually speaking of
Shredder people wanted to stick it to me
over the Cutie Cinderella thing and
here's this yeah he's a small dog I
thought he's gonna live forever like
they say small dogs live forever
he's like I was like 15 years
and then I was like the [__] that was
really [__] me up it was like I don't
even know if Theodore's gonna remember
it now when he gets older
[Music]
you know and in the comments people are
like oh yeah he's not gonna find that
funny it's like shut up idiot it is
definitely fun
and I hope now Zach okay but I feel like
in that moment if I played that dude
that would have been so funny dude so
like that is so funny oh my God you
think I would have been angry at you
yeah yes you would and I would never
like you're having this emotional
stuck you're sick in the head I
personally disagree that I would be
angry
you would just go from crying to
laughing in that moment like how would
you react you would yeah well it should
go from probably shock
the laughter but the truth is that I
would be proud of you for taking that
initiative you would be yes okay maybe
okay okay I'm always encouraging you
okay
I personally I think that that's
in that moment and I hope that now after
we've had this conversation as a gesture
of good faith that next time I'm crying
or super emotional you'll hit me with
that okay fair enough fair enough and in
fact I think anyone on this show getting
emotional should get this Chestnut
treatment okay maybe depending on the
context but maybe we all sign consent
forms to the chestnut
I like that idea I would sign it
it's not even necessarily the song's not
even making fun of you it's kind of like
oh setting the mood
that's the most joyful time of year the
happiest time of the year
two of this was cross-posted
oh all here
but you posted so many times
yeah so okay
by the way fresh and fit is still taking
shots at me they're so desperate for my
attention daddy they're begging me
please this man is this man is tagging
me at 2am
205 am he goes
and he this isn't the first time he's
done this he keeps tagging me like I'm
like I'm looking at his [__] wait
what he goes I could be watching listen
oh and then he he uses the F slur really
Tim has a play on
asanabi which is fine
or lethan decline L3 podcast but I'm
here instead that's right brother you're
up by yourself nobody's at home waiting
for you boy why does he think that it's
one or the other like you could watch
something and exercise people listen to
me well they work out a lot I think
that's like uh yeah this is the people
listen to podcasts but not that he has
to he doesn't know silence nobody nobody
asked you to listen the real irony of
this post is the song he's listening to
dude
I wish I could play it obviously but I'd
listen to it and it is
it's gay club music I don't know what
else to call it it was like it was just
like what okay this whole yes the story
is such a self-report like first of all
you're just proving you have no brain
cells
yeah
Barbados did
here's somebody in the chat just said
I'm on the treadmill right now there you
go that's impossible you have to choose
freaking coconut some Barbados another
one I'm working out right now you know
what I should call fit uh howling at the
moon now howling at the moon Barbados
you Helen at the Moon my boy
yes with the other wolves we love that
for you also one other thing is
says in big letters 205 am but we took
this screenshot at like nine in the
morning and it said 45 minutes ago
wait he's lying about it no I think it
was a Snapchat
and posted to Instagram okay he thought
it was such a banger Post Yeah to spread
the word also sad just to show you how
pathetic this guy is he tags sneako so
he can get he can get his little
boyfriend's approval
hey dude look how [__] cool I am bro
I just I just called uh Hassan the fsler
yeah awesome hey bro put on Howl at the
Moon call me when you're listening to
How at the moon so we can sing together
it's Friday actually
just to keep you in the loop there not
sure if your brain is capable of
tracking the days of the week
but um there it is they're desperate man
I wonder what sneako thought of this
tweet
I tagged snico did you see it he
probably hauled back at the Moon
snakeo saw this one was like oh
wolf pack baby God yes we are packed
only dicks
it was so this dude is just the best man
so many of our listeners are exercising
right now yeah I'm seeing a lot of
multitasking but they're at the dumbass
impossible
the rosie uh Super Chat said songs of
bang or badan called it total gay bar
Vibes and which is it's fine no problem
with the song it's the fact that he's
dropping F slurs while listening yeah
he's just a little the F's Larry's
really it's such a big game man is it a
flex that he's exercising by himself at
205 am it is kind of pathetic it's just
bizarre yes like that means that a
you have nothing to wake up to do
B you have nobody at home who's missing
you is he at this is a gym right yeah it
looks like this guy doesn't have a home
gym he's not he's broke Loser yeah he
can't afford that kind of [__]
and he's he's clearly thinking about you
when when he's doing it dude yeah from
what why am I on your mind at 205 am
just totally unprompted totally unprofit
yeah you haven't talked about in a while
no no I haven't even thought about him
in a while to be honest
so I don't know what's going on but I
hope sneako liked it I kind of feel like
in a way he's saying that maybe deep
down inside he want he wants to watch
the podcast like yes that's all I'm
getting from them because why would he
say I could be watching and all I want
to say is like you can put it on while
you're exercising welcome to the family
no I'm busy howling at the moon
[Music]
all right
just a little shout out to our boy
uh Howlin at the Moon
you know and coconuts and Barbados
love them
thank you
Jesus cured this woman I love when this
happens oh yeah dude this showed up on
my feed rest in peace I don't have a
[__] feet anymore so say goodbye all
this awesome Tick Tock content
yeah here's what read the words yeah
it's just threw me forever you were
representing the gym she goes Jesus what
how do you overcome anxiety low
self-esteem and insecurities he's Jesus
bro her doing pull-ups is like Jesus on
the cross oh my God I thought that edit
was so [__] wild it's a weird take
and then I thought maybe it's a joke but
you could it's not it's not you want to
see what they do hashtags Christian tick
tock
Christian gym talk that's interesting
crossover she's strong I'm impressed but
look well maybe if you lifted bite with
the power of Christ you could also be
strong Maybe
it was also kind of a hype edit I
thought it was pretty dope like anyway
it syncs with the song yeah yeah I hear
it but
that's pretty bad [__] though right
pretty
beautiful
uh so many chat said it's a joke I
thought I thought so too until looking
at the profile it's definitely not a
joke I double checked because it was so
weird it was a joke she is 100 serious
yeah
also here's something that blew my mind
now
we had a similar debate about wiping
we found out that some people wipe from
the front and some people wipe from the
back and they don't know each other
right well so here's another thing
that's currently blowing my mind what
this guy tweeted out my wife said that
introverts have to plan their
conversations in advance is this true
and a lot of comments are like yeah I
have to
conversation hack ask questions but
apparently a lot of people say yes I do
that I don't even understand how that's
possible
how do you plan a conversation in
advance oh you have a show document for
a podcast
I mean I guess I I do yeah I mean I'm an
introvert I guess you could say and I do
that it's not like it's like fully
scripted but uh I'll Think through like
what a com how
the conversation will go before going
and engaging with somebody yeah my brain
will like present me with possible
options and I like beforehand will think
about how
like you like should I comment about
this or yeah you know should I well hold
on are we talking about like let's say
you're having a family gathering
yeah or a friend do you say okay I'm
gonna say hi are you're going to go to a
friend's house that's better because
you're familiar with them
so do you think ahead of time like I
wanna this is what I'm gonna ask my
friend when I'm with her to avoid it
being awkward
I think because sometimes like People
Like Us I think I'm one of those is like
you can end up having when you leave the
room
like we could all meet you and somebody
else okay be together
as long as you're in the room it's all
good once you go to the bathroom it gets
awkward
yeah but that's not and so like somebody
like me sometimes have to like try to
plan to avoid that awkwardness but how
far ahead are you planning
yeah I totally get it too and not like
planning fully but yeah it's not fully
planning yeah or at least if you have an
idea of what topics you want to talk
about and then what you want to say
about those topics so my question is
though when does this planning occur
before you go over to their house like
how far ahead of time are you planning
this if I'm talking to like an
acquaintance who I haven't seen in a
minute and they're like we should grab
lunch or we should do coffee I don't
know if extroverts feel this way too but
I I'll feel like Dread or panic because
it's like me too I'm about to spend time
with someone who I don't necessarily
know yes how well we vibe off of each
other so I'll think of things that like
we have in common or oh I saw that she
went to this place a few months ago so
if I if I need to I'll be sure to ask
about that right
I've never had a thought like that my
whole life yeah because you're the one
that when you enter the room everything
is fine yeah you're not an introvert by
any means
I didn't I know people are gonna think
this is crazy but I feel like in my
private life I'm pretty introverted
I know what you mean but you're not I
don't I
leave your friends over and stuff and
we're just hanging out I don't like
conversations like I don't like I wanted
to I don't like talking to people fears
with friends at the doctor or the
dentist the grocery store I'm giving one
word answers because I don't like I
don't like small talk I hate it
something that I learned that I actually
didn't know is that an introvert means
that it doesn't mean that you don't like
talking to people in public it just
means that your energy source comes from
like you need to recharge yourself and
be alone and extroverts get energy off
of others see I don't get energy off
others others train me
um interesting well maybe you are
introverted then but like it's just I
don't know maybe maybe for me it's a mix
when it comes to you because you're also
just like naturally funny
so you can make every situation like
effortlessly just kind of funny
right girl you know like when I used to
have a job I would go and do like
whatever office job or restaurant or
whatever it is I was doing I was always
super quiet I wasn't like cracking jokes
and stuff really I don't know I don't
know I was just doing my work and I
would [__] go home I don't know if
that's how it's preserved
for others I should have we should ask
someone who was like Sean balog was
there with me a lot of the time oh yeah
the message he does it yeah I don't
think he thinks about it that deeply you
know what I mean oh yeah you were pretty
quiet at work well you did the
myers-brix test and you were an
introvert on that because we had the
same we had the same one and I'm an
introvert the Myers broke that's the the
four letters like right when I started I
think
I don't remember anything about that
well we already we all did a personality
test you had to answer a bunch of
questions and it came up with like
they're all like IG
that well that was the one we did with
Dr Drew no that's just later
I'm definitely an introvert too I would
say and then something that helps me
that a b kind of helped me out with is
if I don't know what to talk about I'll
just ask questions
gave away the sauce I mean that's that's
wow
you know that would be great if they can
help anybody yeah I hate [__] small
talk and I I envy people who could keep
it up that's my one trick is oh ask ask
questions okay give a [__]
I try to just end it man I don't even I
don't think I even have the energy to
pretend that I care
you say that but I've seen you interact
with like yeah I'm running into fans on
the street all the time and you're
really good at it oh well doing that you
know I I will say I love being meeting
fans though I love them I am happy I
love them too but it can be awkward even
with a fan and for you it's not gonna be
okay and I'll be like so
nice to see you okay yeah I know what
you mean I mean you're obviously more
I guess I don't know you have uh it's a
lot worse than anxiety I guess it's just
anxious yeah okay there it is
this is my burden
isn't it funny though like we're social
creatures literally like we are societal
we live in huge [__] cities with
millions of people yeah we're so
exciting so true we're so afraid of
[__] talking to anybody yeah
oh my God I have a good example of that
actually
um so I did a Miss Michigan pageant
before you do what yeah hold up hold up
hold up on tell the story tell the story
talking about talking points to bring up
well it's not so much about the whole
pageant just like this specific moment I
remember because it was so embarrassing
wait how did you place
I didn't win there's only like there's
only one we got second place where she
got robbed super second place that was a
different pageant that wasn't Miss
Michigan wait you're right
I need to I need to know everything okay
wait wait hold on before you say
anything
how many pageants have you competed in
like four yeah four and have you won any
I did I won I won two of them and then
another one I came second runner-out but
it was rigged and I I found out it was
rigged I need to see how did we never
know about this yeah you want two beauty
pageants
and everything you're like officially a
Quinn like you you have the title I
would tell everyone all the time hold up
it was like a decade ago now so hold on
you're just gonna walk around the office
yeah that's a two-time beauty pageant
winner amongst us
what do I do just walk in here guys I'm
a beauty queen yeah let us know you're
better than us what are you talking
about yeah we haven't been following
protocols that is your body privileged
girl that is why
because I well I asked her did you win
and I I thought I was like she's gonna
say yes she goes no I didn't win we're
not second place
how many people were in that pad in the
pageants
um the biggest one was probably
um
I'm trying to think the Miss Dearborn
one there was a lot of girls
um and then miss Michigan that was
pretty big too because it's girls from
all over the state so wait the mission
the Miss Michigan that's the one you got
second place
yes no no I'm sorry not miss Michigan
there is a different one the um I'm
trying to think of how how they titled
it was like Arabian princess or
something like that it's kind of racist
yeah no but it was like it was in
Michigan and there was something yeah
it's a little weird
there's a princess in the title
it's just I don't know maybe I'm off it
sounds funny to me do you have the crown
in the sash still I do I'll wear that on
Monday yeah
looking at the office yeah
you need to wear that during the show
apparently give us a princess wave
she was looking like everywhere for her
first place one while we were in
Michigan oh yeah oh my God the Miss
nothing Olivia I did have to for Miss
Arabian princess there was like some
events I had to like attend after I won
wow and for one of them I sat on one of
those like long bench couches and these
guys held me up on it as I walked in
that was my endurance and it was so
awkward and I had to like wave to people
that's a dream a dream that's your duty
as Princess yeah this is what you wanted
you have princess obligations we all
knew that you were a princess but you
have the receipt like this is crazy I
got some friends so crazy wait did you
win money or anything
um I did it wasn't like a huge amount of
money but like you also went herbs and
stuff wait how what did you win I need
numbers I mean there's different pad
s what's the biggest prize you got
prize was 5
000 wow serious cheddar so Amy you were
there for all that uh I was not it was
uh shortly after yeah did you know that
you were dating a beauty queen I did
actually that's the first time I seen a
picture of Lena was that pageant oh yeah
years later yeah before I met her
what did you think in your mind the
first time you saw a picture of her
uh very very good
very very good
Miss Arabian for instance I was I was
like Vin Diesel
yeah can you actually I don't know if
you mind but can you bring a crown and
Sack yes please they're all at my mom's
house somewhere in storage I'll ask her
if she can look for them
thank you but they they're still there I
have proof and so um was that the
awkward story you wanted to tell about
how they carry doing oh no no so what is
it so the awkward stories because when
you do the interview when you're on
stage with the judges
um and they give you an idea of like
what kind of questions they'll be asking
they won't tell you exactly what but I
knew that one one question I kind of
prepared for but not so much is that um
what did they say oh just making a
difference in the world or something
along that those lines and so when I
went up there my question was what would
you oh what's your goal in life and I
said because I I figured they might ask
something like that I said um to make a
difference in the world before I leave
it and what threw me off then they asked
me and how do you plan to do that okay
which isn't a hard question to answer
um I could have just given like another
generic answer like my first one
um but just because it threw me off and
I just kind of froze I didn't know
completely went blank so that's what
like it's helpful to at least get an
idea or prepare in advance
what about tell me about the one that
was rigged which one was that you got
second place why didn't you yes please
tell this one it was like a Miss Lebanon
kind of um
pageant but anyways for that one I I
know it was rigged because one of the
photographers told he came up to me
afterwards and he was just talking and
he he wanted me to do like this TV show
or something anyways there was like
opportunities that came from it
um I didn't like follow I didn't go
through with those but
um that's how we were talking and he
told me that him and the other
photographers were like directed as to
who to focus on which contested
tell them about the final question you
had Lena oh so yeah my question which I
thought was a good reply but and this
one they didn't prepare you like you
don't know what they're going to ask but
they said who has a tougher job is a
housewife or a businesswoman and I said
a housewife because she doesn't have
like a Punch-Out card at the end of the
day great answer that's a good answer it
doesn't stop
um but yeah I didn't win so okay so now
I have solved this case because one of
the judges was on this TLC show TLC came
to our hometown and made a show called
All-American Muslim that we try to bury
we don't talk about it that bad it's
pretty bad but one of the ladies who was
a judge for that pageant is on the show
and continuously throughout the show she
keeps saying that she's a businesswoman
she wants respect as a businesswoman she
said business woman so many times Selena
[__] up by saying that a mom is more
crucial what kind of [__] show is
that though where they're like there's
one right answer
I mean corrupt there's corruption even
in the pageants this world is just not
just that's the Dearborn show baby that
was a great answer though Lino yeah
thank you well I vote for Lena for Miss
Dearborn
that's the one I won can I say uh I
don't mean to diss your city but the
name of it sounds like a tick-borne
virus
Dearborn it sounds like some kind of
[__] lethal disease you get from a
tick bite or something I never thought
about it that way but I mean I I agree I
mean it's fitting it's an interesting
place was there like a career
for you in mind we're attending those
like did you want to be something
not necessarily it just started like
when when I won the first pageant it
gave me the like admission into the next
pageant
um like when I got missed Dearborn for
example I had free registration and
entry where usually there's fees
Associated but I got all of that for
free into the Miss Michigan pageant I
got to compete so well look at us crew
we're all full of surprises Lena that
just blew my mind yeah
we actually have a special caller here
today the uh some love them some hate
them it's infobren we discovered this
guy we washed them together
he goes into Walmart and just
brutalizes I just want you to know the
cops have been called this you guys
remember this they're on their way oh
man he wears he wears spy glasses did
you watch this again no I don't know did
he wears spy glasses and he goes into
grocery stores
what are glasses like sunglasses yeah so
they don't know recording
do I know you
okay yeah that makes it so much better
I would just be honest with them when
they get here
okay who are you just to save you some
trouble just be honest oh my God I'm
Brent what Bren Brent yeah I never heard
it I never heard well that's fine I'm
just giving you a warning they're on
their way okay
so what did I do I would just stick
around what did I do
you think I'm stupid
yeah do you think I'm still waiting we
had a really mixed reaction when I
showed really just because and I get it
right because like how bad do you feel
for this guy let's bring in bran let's
pick his brain let's see who's the Mad
genius box when I saw that we were going
to talk to this guy I checked out the
tick tocks but I didn't know that so I
was assuming it's just like a phone or
something
oh no these are real as a heart attack
and then now knowing that I love it
there he is a lot more info bran uh
welcome to the show
hello
well [__] in my esophagus you want to
climb on top of this I absolutely do
thank you
absolutely
so Brent let me ask you this do you have
a personality disorder or something
I don't know you're a doctor
I don't have any clinical uh abilities
no I bite you know I've never been to
one
so
um
do you ever get yeah okay
micropenis support Club I see back there
is that a member a party or group you're
a part of yeah that's a friends actually
yeah yeah so that's pretty small what
we're seeing with the fingers there oh
yeah of course
that is pretty small hey by the way get
with of these huh what happened to your
hand
it seems to be drenched in some kind of
red fluid bro what are you covered in
blood
I'm taking a break from a rousing game
of hemorrhoid Hunters oh god dude that
is so disgusting
and did you find it good time for you
did you win the game what was the
results
Kenneth only ever wins the game yeah
there's no losers in hemorrhoid Hunter
by the way I just want to say
it is an honor to be on
and you're looking real good really
thanks bro I feel like that was genuine
worse no you're looking real good thanks
bro real good
so when you when you approach people and
where do you usually prowl is it Walmart
or Target or if you mix it up
Wally World Wally world that's I'm
assuming Walmart yeah do you find the
land of opportunity
and do you find the people in Walmart
are special breed that it lends to the
kind of content you make
I mean if they are I'm part of that
breed you know damn right right you're
amongst your own yeah right and how is
this now I want to get an experience of
being approached by Yeah by Bren and the
and the Walmart how close do you get to
these people it seems you get very close
oh I don't know probably
four feet maybe each time something like
that I'm wearing hidden camera glasses
yeah can we see it and they usually make
me appear like I'm standing a bit closer
oh but I try to keep a little bit of
distance you know here here are the
glasses right they actually work really
good yeah it's kind of amazing pretty
subtle right are those expensive glasses
like that they seem really Tech these
were like 250 these are actually my
second pair that I had that's worth it I
was working with a pair I bought these
ones like eight years ago and the lens
is a little bit more noticeable there
oh yeah
okay I see I'm actually surprised no
one's ever called me out on on wearing
these and then the lenses came out they
were actually Shades to start with
[Music]
um
but yeah they just croaked on me so I
had to buy these uh these came from
China I believe
well I gotta say
um
I'm a fan of your work
uh I think I I'm a big fan I think what
you do is incredible do you are you not
are you not like scared sometimes to do
this to approach strangers in this way
have you ever been like
maybe this maybe I shouldn't be talking
to this person right now
oh Ethan I get off on it yeah you must
yeah
absolutely I just crave social
interaction
really there we go we found our
extrovert yeah
of course yeah do you know ahead of time
what you're gonna say to them
I find it's better if I kind of go in
without a plan really
yeah sometimes obviously like I can't
help but think of a good line when I'm
just
sitting at home and I'll write it down
but usually the best videos come when I
just kind of work off the Dome you know
what I'm saying now when you approach
people are you wearing a bloody shirt
like the one you're wearing now or
I could definitely throw them on
only after I've played hemorrhoid
Hunters so occasionally I do sometimes
actually during the summer
um I'm usually just naturally dirty from
work so I'll come I'll hit up a Walmart
after work when I'm driving home or
something and I'll be covered in like I
seal coat for a living so I'll be
covered in Black wait what do you do for
a job what is your work
um we do uh traffic markings and part of
that consists of sealcoating parking
lots striping roads oh so you're you're
a working man
yes sir you're uh salt to the Earth kind
of guy of course yeah absolutely and so
you I like that so you come home all
nasty and Dusty and [__] and you just
get right into it oh yeah especially
during steel kind of Seasons dude your
dedication is really something man I
gotta say uh I I think there's only
maybe a handful of people in the entire
world that could do what you do
thank you I really appreciate that it
means a lot yeah
um here's one this is one of my favorite
ones I think this is the first one I saw
of yours
you approached this guy oh what do you
yeah did you see something on your
sleeve
videos what is this spaghetti
SpaghettiOs
spaghetti that's in your shirt pocket is
that right oh yeah
I was feeling famished it's got
meatballs we'll see yes don't do it yeah
filthy Frank special and do you kind of
just you you do you usually eat your
lunch out of your shirt pocket like that
or is
if I'm busy
is it
cold or is it room temp
the spaghetti oh it's cold
I only eat them cold that's the best way
yeah that doesn't look like a heated
room wherever you are right now yeah no
no my nipples are rock hard right now so
the SpaghettiOs are on Ice oh what what
kind of uh where do you live about
hold on
I'm gonna watch that now are you called
spinach pickles
let me see the was that a butthole
yeah it's my butthole oh look that looks
like a close-up of a end of a hot dog
no it's my butthole what do you think
you like it it's clean well yeah I try
to keep it clean of course no
whereabouts it starts to snow a little
bit like green tarry stool you know what
I'm saying oh no see that that is just
foul dude shame on you
whereabouts do you live in the country
Washington State
okay interesting so that's kind of
find some characters around there I was
gonna say he's the most normal Pacific
Northwest yeah you might be the most
normal guy in the state I might be yeah
I don't know we'll see about that you
know and are you do you have any plans
of quitting your day job and pursuing
harassing people full-time
that would be lovely Ethan
that would absolutely be lovely you know
I've been having back problems
and I feel like if I could just stop
doing what I'm doing right now I could
prevent further
you know chronic pain down the line
right but the chronic pain might be part
of the what we like about the character
it's true maybe
maybe wise man and I gotta say you have
the drippiest little earlobes oh thank
you so much thanks for noticing what
just flick those puppies all day long
baby that make you that makes me very
uncomfortable
absolutely what do you say we get
underneath the blanket you know I got a
flashlight you just flick them all day
long
yeah I'm gonna pass on that okie doke
thank you though appreciate that
are you but you got to be making some
money from your Tick Tock now right is
there I mean I don't know how Tick Tock
isn't you know known for paying very
well
yeah I make a little bit and it does
save my ass especially in the winter
time because we don't get much work in
the winter time so I'm grateful yeah
it's a it's it's a little bit but it's
enough to kind of pay my bills and damn
because I also get unemployment and then
that goes into it too I wonder what can
we do to
build this into like a bigger kind of
platform where you can make a little
more sustainable money I do I don't know
if you have a cameo but I feel like
you'd be great at it oh Cameo have you
thought about that I do have a cameo
okay okay what is it let's shout it out
add info Brian on Cameo okay info brand
on Cameo so that's good Valentine's Day
is coming up so if you want to reap out
the misses
also speaking of which
I just want to say if you are planning
on sending your ex flowers for
Valentine's Day don't
send them just any flowers send them
this specific flour
found on infobren.com
I love that we coat each and every one
of our flowers
in ass juice okay the special smell
it smells pretty pretty foul oh my God
imagine if you sent that to your mama
well if you hate your mom
maybe leave that on the gravestone of
your enemy and don't waste it on anybody
who's experiencing uh like covid-19 or
anything because I hear
it may kill them well no no I mean they
can't even smell it anyway
yeah it doesn't matter if it kills them
I don't care about that right right I
understand yeah but I wonder how we can
build this into a
yeah into a real career for you do you
have a YouTube channel maybe mixing some
long-form kind of content
I do yes I I have uh it's the same name
on YouTube
um I used to actually I started it in
2012.
your cat yeah
hi Kitty yeah I'm trying to get up into
that sphincter juice you know what I'm
saying he smells it yeah
no but I used to do I don't know if
you've ever seen I used to do the uh sex
noises in the library videos like 10
years ago
that's actually how I discovered you
back in the days I've been watching for
a long time okay okay by the way this is
infer brand on YouTube uh almost 200 000
Subs we love to see it let me sort by
popular sex noises in the library I've
never seen this
you're not gonna claim me are you bran
no
no no no
or start with the second one maybe yeah
that's maybe better second one's better
all right let me go back here sex noise
in the Library part two yeah this one's
not good
foreign
that's me in the green hoodie there
I totally remember this video whoa
what happened to you man you have fallen
on Hard Times my friend oh yeah well
this is all intentional it's all
intentional yeah of course I I gained
about 50 pounds in the last year just uh
people didn't say that I matched my
voice so
dude you are dedicated man I love what
you do
have you always wanted to do comedy are
you uh is that what your ambition is to
be a comedian absolutely yeah you are
funny man yeah and you're Fearless
definitely you're a [__] friend have
you ever tried stand up I have yeah I
used to do open mics over at the Tacoma
Comedy Club as another one of my
characters Silas Brown
who's a real pompous son of a [__]
wears a turtleneck you know
and my first time actually I mean they
tell you when you go up for your first
time that uh it's like crickets but I I
did really well so why don't you why
didn't you keep it up
it's work in life yeah I just get into a
rhythm of going back and back you know
yeah you ever think of moving to the big
city coming down to La take a swing at
Showbiz
wait I don't know man I'm not a I'm not
a city boy really by nature but uh I do
like it down there I visited down there
a few times
hey want to know a funny story
sure yeah think you're not gonna believe
this this is actually kind of kind of
wild but I was once the star
of a uh gay pornography on the internet
you were the star yes a non-sexual role
but
[Laughter]
but no this is all a true story I'm I'm
dead ass serious so this guy hit me up
uh via the emails about late 2021.
and he was a big uh like fan of my
content and I was doing the same thing
kind of I'm doing now creeping people
out and all that
and he said hey I'm uh it said like big
opportunity you know and he's like hey
I'm a
I'm a producer and he goes on to say you
know he's obviously like a porno
producer like uh the gay porno that
variety yeah the variety yeah yeah
and he goes you know um I'd love to fly
you down here to Vegas and uh kind of
get you into this production that I'm
working on he bought like this trailer
park out in the desert right abandoned
trailer park like [__] five miles out
of the day I think it's Pahrump
you know
Nevada yeah
and uh
she kind of tells me he's like yeah uh I
want you to basically do
what you do on Tick Tock but it's going
to end with a bunch of dudes [__]
each other why why does he think that'd
be good and he goes you don't have to be
part of that I just want you to
basically you're going to be going up to
these people in a trailer park and it's
gonna look like you're you know creeping
them out and then when you hand them the
and at that time I had a bleach beers a
year when you hand them the bleach
you're gonna convince them to drink it
and then they're gonna get all horny and
just start boning each other
why does he think that that was and did
you accept the offer
I did yeah he he paid me four grand
which took like five hours of my time
damn so how did it start out there all
paid food and everything it was lovely
you know he promised I wouldn't see
anything but and I'm a little upset
because I ended up seeing some [__]
some rather large
it's fine uh you know I can understand
as you're a member of the micro penis
Sapporo Club
well that is interesting um yeah what is
the name we'll we'll fact check that uh
another time
yeah well um I never saw it
let me I'm gonna watch this video I'm
sure if it made it to huh final point
you don't want your own work well I
think do you think this guy maybe was
razzing you up maybe it's not maybe this
guy was getting off on you watching two
dudes have sex and maybe there was no
gay porn he brought you out to the
middle of nowhere so that for his own
weird Private Collection have you
thought about that
just some [__] like Rich dude who
just wants yeah I mean that's that's
definitely a possibility
but you did get paid at the end of the
day so I I did hey let me let me I'm in
Vegas too let me sneak a peek at this
here
actually making the sound oh yeah
so you you have a even when you looked
like a fresh young buck with his future
ahead of him unlike now uh you you were
uh you were you were comfortable making
people uncomfortable
uh absolutely
interesting I I realized early on that
uh there's no reason
to feel uncomfortable in a social
interaction you know and once you
realize that and start to kind of have
fun with it it's life-changing you know
absolutely life-changing you could be a
life coach yeah there's a lot of people
that could benefit from your uh yeah
your doubts we were just talking about
it today about the Dao of Bren most of
us here are introverts and yeah
don't know what to say in conversations
it's like jumping into a pool the first
time but then you just start to love it
there it is
[Music]
oh God yeah dude you're so crazy for
this this is nuts
also like I don't know if this is how
you normally dress but you look so
unassuming yeah like so it's normal okay
friends getting up there for
grabbing something
I was just grabbing my cat you know
can I ask you a question are you by
yourself or are you with friends when
you're filming this
uh with those ones early on I always had
at least someone with me to be like the
camera guy yeah
nowadays I'm always by myself
and it's much easier that way I don't
have to count on anyone to get content
you know there's something about going
out there by yourself that is ex
um
particularly psycho psychotic to me
[__] it's just crazy dude what you do I
feel like especially with them not
knowing that there's a camera involved
because a lot of times we shot stuff out
in the you know with people out in the
open and I would be holding the camera
so it was almost like a a shield like
well they know we're just doing
something for the camera so you feel
more comfortable because of that at
least for me but in your case it's like
pure psycho energy
in my case it ruins it because then they
know it's a joke right I just want them
to think that's I'm actually a
psychopath yeah so do you do you usually
put content on or has [__] going gone so
sideways ever that you couldn't even
post it
no actually I always post everything I
film unless there's like a technical
difficulty where it's just
extremely boring or the camera guy
something like that but
um
I think one of my craziest videos at
least within the last couple years is
it's my first pinned video
on on The Tick Tock page and it's the
fisherman video
well chew on my wenis sorry
I'm gonna open it up so we can see
yeah so it's the pinned one or I don't
know if actually pin doesn't work on
desktop your ab's grabbing it from okay
yeah so go on I'll pull it up as you
describe it
of course so so uh
so this dude was just probably as insane
as me maybe even a little bit more see
that must have scared you because you're
doing shtick but this guy's actually the
real deal well I kind of felt like we
were like vibing off each other okay
okay yeah and it was the first time
where like one of these
um really kind of took off because I got
this the tuna juice
yeah check this out yeah this guy's a
legend I have seen this this is the one
that this man sniffs your bloody finger
yes and that blew my [__] mind with
tuna juice on it and then and then he
drinks the tuna juice here let's take a
look so this this is kind of the most
off the walls one you've had I feel like
it is yeah just now when you walked away
from this guy where you're like wow that
was really something
um especially so and just before you
start it to give you little context look
for this while you're watching it
because I definitely could sense that
the things I was saying as random as
they were he was somehow misinterpreting
them to be
like gay comments you know
against it and he wanted something a
little bit more than tuna juice okay he
wanted some brain juice
we have a request to see the cat is that
possible absolutely come here well Nikki
people are loving the loving the kitty
come on little Nikki hey buddy
is that an homage to Adam Sandler's uh
character absolutely I love Adam Sandler
[Music]
we love that see he's a real see ever
that softens people yeah
that's adorable yeah he's like a year
old
oh wow maybe all right let's see your
kindred spirit out there in a Walmart so
what was that that's from a good time
let me tell you you want to smell it
what kind of [__] who would smell
that it's crazy
I can't tell if you're cool or not right
now I don't know oh I'm cool with [__]
buddy dolphin died five five
you want some
always wait we're here on the same kind
of mode aren't we it's made for finches
what did he mean by that he said we're
on the same wavelength right now so
that's what you mean wavelength yeah I'm
probably I think Matt maybe he was
talking about meth
I don't want to get too specific you
know
some kind of drug yeah that was my
impression oh that's cool I like how
he's like yo my dog we're in here
together right this is awesome but
humans can drink it too Finland finches
that's where you're from Finland no it's
tuna juice and it's made for finches but
humans can drink it too
haha
you want to taste I'm a commercial this
man yeah tuners my thing to fish for a
bit like what is this
it's carbonated tuna juice it's made for
finches but humans can drink it too
hey people from Finland are humans too
no it's made for it's made for finches
finches
no that's delicious finches it's made
for finches but humans can drink it too
okay it's a little bird
I have 10 of them
it's tuna juice this is unreal for the
finches but humans can drink it too
try this again
dude this is crazy no
it's selling me a product right now are
you of course not I would never it's got
69 calories 69.
[Laughter]
that's the company it comes from so
there is alcohol let me ask you what's
in the can
uh it's usually just seltzer water okay
okay yeah nice
um actually sometimes I use like a
Budweiser zero which is not completely
not oh that makes some things
that's good I like how you do that and
well how do you do that you design the
labels and you kind of glue them on like
what's the process of creating those so
um it's it's not actually my company
um the guy linked up with me to promote
them but it's uh his name's Kyle and he
runs this company it's called beersee
and that's what they are and they just
slide over like right now oh I'll be
honest
behind the curtain wow you can get uh a
ton of them on uh his website
beersee.com or mine it all comes from
the same place but on infobrand.com you
actually get all these which were
specifically we curated these ones first
I see that yeah that's cool hey that's
awesome thanks for sharing that that's
super cool absolutely
there could be
here try this again
come from
well you're the best salesman I've ever
met that came from buckets
sardine paste in the trunk of my Accord
if you want to meet me out there and
dunk your head in it with me huh wait
with you yeah is this really happening
it's really happening
I can't tell if you're gay or a thousand
oh my God I'm not sure are you gay
salesman you ever have pickled sphincter
huh
I could see how you would misinterpret
The Pickled sphincter uh moment there
it's weird because that one's better
than that one what's your name Brenna
yeah
try this again
five times are you gonna meet me out
there or what
yeah where
out in the parking lot we'll get real
weird real wild no I can already go yeah
you're like you're like the dude I met
on Craigslist
yeah we gotta find the duty mid on
Craigslist
yeah he's my kind of guy what an
encounter my goodness yeah
that's special that was a special moment
you had there with him
absolutely and uh there was there was a
part two but basically uh he ended up
following me to check out and the
conversation continued and uh I was able
to avoid
doing any gay stuff in my Honda Accord
with him by uh he he just happened to
bring up the fact that he was crab
fishing over the summer and I said well
speaking of crabs you know I I got a ton
of crabs down there I just want to let
you know it goes oh so
so so I should just leave right now then
yeah nice job
speaking of crap he's speaking of crabs
I have AIDS
yo um also this happened recently you
had this incredible story arc with this
guy who you went to you said the cops
are coming this video got what like 15
million views and then you did a ton of
videos with him how did that all work
out
so
um he obviously ended up seeing the
video I think one of his co-workers
showed it to him and he commented on it
and uh about the comment I went to his
page and sure enough there's a video of
him like dancing around and his
apartment or whatever and I was like oh
[__] so I reached out I asked him to
meet me at Walmart oh and then uh as
soon as I got out of my truck you know I
I had the glasses on and I got another
video
with him just doing my thing again and
after that I kind of got him like uh
dropped the character a bit I kind of
asked him like what was his thoughts on
what happened the first time and I got
that in a video as well yeah which I
don't usually do hello Maurice hey Brian
how you doing I'm doing good
so our video got 10 million views how do
you feel about that I just want you to
know the cops have been so are you guys
homies now because you guys made a ton
of videos together
yeah yeah
hello Marie that's so that's so uh
awesome that's magical yeah yeah making
friends the most [__] up way possible
we had a little uh birthday swore away
soiree for me uh the other week which he
came to and uh oh that's awesome as well
and then some of the guys I met at my
Meetup also came out dude that is
awesome yeah yeah so um
I gotta say man I think you got a lot of
talent yeah I think you got a lot of
potential you're super funny and you're
Fearless so keep going dude and um
I don't know what do we do from here you
have a plan you got a planner you just
want to keep grinding I'm just gonna
keep trucking yeah you know as they said
um and I just want to thank you again
for having me on and before uh before
you guys take off yeah
I want to ask you have you
ever wanted to tarnish
the relationship between maybe a friend
or someone you know and their
male person
yes
yes all the time I did
all right so do I have the thing for you
these are prank packages which you can
get on my website infobrend.com or BRZ
once again
on the website other beers merch but
they come like this they show up at the
door like oh my god dude that is so wild
the world's biggest dildos
[Laughter]
sphincter we got a um
gay porn mag of the month club
and the drag queen starter kit you know
that's just something for everybody you
know we got used granny panties here
yeah those are great actually um
actually one of them as well which I
hung up there for you all to see so I
love it I love it man thank you I wonder
what I wonder hmm
you know how like we try I try to get
white cloud Gabe to interact with people
but like obviously that's not his thing
we gotta send you out to like Ace Fest
bro
yeah
one of these YouTube he's considered
he's considering perhaps collaborating
or hiring yeah on the scene reporter for
us yeah it would be a man on the street
for us yeah you're our man on the street
would you be open to that
I would absolutely be open to that hell
yeah that'd be fun what is it called
again I'm sorry well I just threw it
there was another one too early last
year it's nothing specific but I want to
send you places but like yeah if there's
some kind of a
event of influencers maybe or like adult
con or fistfest yeah
yes okay okay that sounds good we got a
finger Fest as well
bro imagine you're going to like adult
car getting people to smell your finger
that'd be so wild one of C man's parties
perhaps oh yeah oh my God oh my God all
right we're gonna figure this out we'll
be in touch but I think I think we gotta
we have to continue this journey we need
to find a way to collaborate yeah yeah
yeah I am totally down 100 thank you in
for brand forever and by the way our
I'll be honest our audience was kind of
torn on your content at first because
for obvious reasons right but I feel
like you've won everybody over after our
conversation that's right it's all
enthusiasm for info brand here at the A3
podcast
thank you for having me on and you two
take care
thanks buddy you you keep doing your
thing yeah keep it up thanks man well
our welcome all right
see ya bye bye
[Applause]
you gotta get real close to the camera
see you later just gonna hit the dusty
trail
I feel that
all right see you buddy things to do
places to be
yep us too yeah no I got a whole show to
do so oh yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm just
getting out of here yeah me too [__] off
me too all right
cool cool take care now okey doke you as
well
all right
all right I'll catch you okay happy new
months to you as well
all right well we're gonna we'll take it
on out of here thanks for coming on
thank you for coming
with me on this journey as well
all righty talk to you later uh-huh yeah
all right
I like it staring at those tears fears
for hours let me tell you
all right take care everybody all right
all right we'll talk we'll talk we'll
catch you later yeah
now it's just love hi love
hi wow
you know what when you get people like
this on you never know what to expect
yeah
I love it oh great he was a great one
man yep
he kind of has the act the reminds me in
some ways as the Fleshlight guy I feel
like those two guys are on the same
wavelength oh yeah yeah
oh man uh he's so talented I actually
wish him I hope he's out there and can
uh
make a living
yeah but there you go you guys see he
won you all over
can I say that Olivia
Olivia just passed me a note
she said my friend texted me yesterday
that her brother hooked up sister she
missed she missed I was typing it quick
so your friend's sister hooked up with
the flashlight guy my friend was
watching yes yes how did we know that it
was him well so my friend from school
was watching the steamies yesterday sent
me a photo that she was watching it and
I was like oh my God love that and she
goes OMG my sister hooked up with the
flashlight guy because you were talking
about it and I didn't really ask
follow-up questions but I can should
have yeah
holy [__] that is interesting yeah I'll
get info yeah I want to know uh
I want to know everything I also do did
they use the flashlights tell me
everything yeah exactly I want to know
if that made him a better lover or what
yeah you know your ELO says did this was
this guy a predator I don't know that
was the peanut butter guy yeah no he's a
he's a funny comedian guy he's a good
guy the peanut butter guy actually
turned out to be like a [__] predator
well there's allegations right
or no I think he's on the registry right
I don't know there was a bunch of stuff
that came out about him
well shocking I know the guy who [__]
peanut butter for content is a weirdo
well anyway that was super fun yeah and
for bran everybody so those Library
pranks are some like true OG content but
the good ones you know not a faker yeah
back in the days I remember that video
that you pulled up I had no idea it was
the same guy dude Austin Butler who we
talked about who's changed his voice and
uh yeah now he's out there because he's
been getting goofed on pretty hard for
this now he's out there saying he's
trying to turn his voice back
all right Austin
I remember when I talked to you uh
Christopher Khan the the the Elvis voice
was still very present in your voice and
people have talked about that but I
think there's a lot less of it now I'm
glad you say that I hear it all the time
dude you are not serious this man is a
[__] goon that was that was already
kidding me I'm glad you said that I'm
glad you said that well thank you very
much
what the [__] bro this voice was still
very present in your voice and people
have talked about that but I think
there's a lot less of it now I'm glad
you say that oh my God he should be the
Joker I feel like he's kid plays a joker
he kind of got the face for it
well oh thank you for saying that
sweetheart
oh
I hear it all the time so do you think
will it will it eventually go have you
tried your video have you gone to a
speech therapist or anything
what did you sound like before yeah
people pull clips from when I was 17.
it's not even his voice it's his Cadence
he's trying he's talking like an
old-timey yeah exactly it's not only
your voice he's such full of [__] that's
not a real thing like the whole language
oh well we get claimed that's a good
question I don't know
probably [__] but I want to watch it
like before yeah
people pull clips from when I was 17.
I talked a little more normal
oh thank you I didn't know
I think it sounded crazy
and it's really I mean to be honest I
really I heard my publicist told me the
other day you know people I don't I try
to stay off social media so my
Publishers told me you know people are
talking about your voice these sorts of
things and it really made me
self-conscious for a second because I
thought
it really made me self-conscious for a
minute we didn't have Instagram
yeah you know uh back in my day we
didn't even have smartphones
yeah made me self-conscious lag can they
tell I'm trying to talk like Elvis all
right
oh thank you very much
thanks for having me on
I don't I try to style social media so
my publicist told me you know people are
talking about your voice and these sorts
of things it really made me
self-conscious for a second because I
thought here's an idea if you're such a
great actor why don't you pretend like
your voice sounds like a normal [__]
human being I was thinking the same
thing don't you want to get other jobs
yeah you know like people are gonna be
like well we can't have him be Elvis
yeah he's Elvis now he's gonna be in
like some movie about like a teacher in
a in a inner city you know trying to
change these kids life who cares Elvis
Presley yeah
come on oh oh yeah do this math equation
yeah
[Music]
he's gonna be in Doom too for real
so what is he gonna sound like yeah or
maybe they shot it before Elvis
uh uh no we gotta get that spice yeah
they're shooting the second one like now
or just recently so it would definitely
be after so yeah we might get Elvis in
Space the old hound dog
taking all the spies
yeah yeah
am I being phony is this not my voice
and
um and and then I thought no I'd have to
think consciously to not talk how I am
right now but my voice yeah do that bro
this is ridiculous sorry I know how in
Dune you have to walk in a certain way
to not attract the sand worms when
you're outside or whatever Blue Suede
Shoes
crazy
[Laughter]
oh [__]
it's crazy dog I want to talk to my dad
when I'm here right now you know we all
have different bits of ourselves that
we're releasing
um I was really questioning it I thought
okay for one thing I'm older now
I don't I maybe sometimes I have a
southern twang but I'm not I don't think
this is something you're from he's from
L.A [__] ain't no sudden Southern twang
it is from Disneyland yeah that's where
Disneyland is yeah yeah
come on now come on
sound like Elvis I would sound very
different right now don't do it yeah
but the other thing is I think I from
all the singing I I probably have
destroyed my voice a bit you know my
vocal nice try dude yes
time to move on bro
time to move on I gotta use the bathroom
that's like if the Peewee go ahead the
Pee-wee Herman guys like I have to talk
like this now oh wow this is just my
voice
hi daddy that's my bye
dude
bye good morning
I knew you were what am I sometimes your
voice just changes
dancing tequila
let him go
I feel like my throat is especially
tight and [__] yeah
yeah that's a interesting way to
describe it it's hard feeling man I know
the feeling it's hard to do any kinds of
raspy voice
that's my specialty
really well Alex Jones one at least oh
yeah see I can't do that for very long
my throat just kind of craps out
there you go I played Alex Jones and now
I just talk like this [__] I'm gonna be
in the next Dune movie playing as uh all
trades
apologize infowar spice right now
there's a war for your mind despise it
open your mind Hey Hillary Clinton the
lifespan Hillary Clinton works for the
uh panachaw emperor
I don't know I'll tell you what folks
they called me more of deed
and uh I my food has made a rat pellets
just like uh you find in the desert
there and that's why it's high quality
stuff here folks infowars.com the elites
want you to burn your mind with the
machines but we outlined artificial
intelligence
yeah that's right
[Music]
thank you Alex I just talk like it is
now
I played Alex Jones in a bit on my show
and now my voice is stuck like this I
sing too much as Alex Jones it turns
into uh Tom Waits right
there that is huh Austin Butler
everybody
The Man Who Can't Let It Go
okay what we need to do next is this
Jeffree Star Tom Brady right our Point
yeah I need to go
throat goat Jeffree Star did release a
tweet this week that said he was the
throat goat oh he did yeah so it's a
wonderful transition nice Segway
well shout out Jeffree Star
[Music]
um I'm going to uh go to the bathroom
and then we'll get into this Jeffree
Star is Jeffree Star dating Tom Brady
which might sound silly but it's way
more interesting than you think so I'll
be right back how bad you have to pee
right now really bad foreign
I guess we'll get into it but I have
some money riding on it can we get a
perfect a preemptive poll going here uh
oh yeah maybe yeah it would be a good
idea to pull before and after yeah do
you want to seeing the evidence Jeffy
star is banging out Tom Brady TV 12. all
right I'll word it just like that he
ain't deflating those balls cam Jeffy
star is banging out Tom Brady tb12
that's what he said
yes no roll it that pull
yes no or bad pull those are the options
here we go
see what we got
oh Sophie thank you for the 20 gifted
thank you for the gifted
I really I can't do it
[Applause]
uh what if Ethan stuck uh voice got
stuck as The Godfather voice
that would
that would start I'll be ruin his vocal
that'd be the end of me working on this
show what it would be oh so 36 of the
audience thinks that Jeffree Star and
Tom Brady are an item you guys are nuts
you're [__] nuts okay well 64 isn't
thinking with their hearts
though Olivia
is fully convinced because it's it's
just what's happening I don't know what
to tell you but there's no evidence
Jeffree Star
we'll talk about it we'll get into it
we'll talk about it we'll get into it I
just I don't think TB would he ain't the
Fly Guy keep saying he ain't deflating
those balls so you know hey
what who's to say
we are today actually yep getting
messages from Ethan in the bathroom
right now asking us to add things to the
doc we're planning the episode in real
time for the bathroom right now what is
this
uh
oh this is actually really funny yeah we
should uh
we should cover this Elon another Elon l
i see
huh
I've added it I've added it Ethan we're
in
[Music]
here Ethan doing the Elon ma boys from
the bathroom
[Laughter]
so I'm gonna end this I'm gonna end this
poll what we were finding out from the
audience before seeing all the evidence
where they stand on the Jeffree Star Tom
Brady thing well of course it's going to
be no but like you guys have to compel
us it's 40 yes approximately 40 yes 60
no yeah for about 40 of this audience
thinks that they like okay let's assume
that Tom Brady just got out of this
long-term relationship he's been married
for a long time he's got a family and
let's say that he's bisexual or gay and
he's been Desiring to have sex with a
man
now he's not hitting up Jeffrey's star
he's hitting me up that's what's gonna
happen yeah I mean I I would I would
prefer that
but why Jeff why would you I don't know
I don't know just Jeffree Star I mean
apparently he's the throat goat so you
can find better than that I guess maybe
you can't find better throat than that
I've heard it's a good throw
that's what I hear but it's not TB
Worthy
what's TV Tom Brady
yeah the goat let's get into it throat
goat they call him the goat what's that
what's that about what is that oh by the
way
one thing I wanted to oh we got a
picture of Lena oh my gosh here let's
see oh no way
and she's got the Sash on and everything
wow
look at all these losers you're up
against
was it say second runner-up
2012. this is the girl who beat you
yeah this is the one that was rigged
Lena
I just got back
um Greg well yeah so the first the one
who won yeah they were the photographers
knew to focus on her and then the one
next to her who's this that is yomana K
Roos a living legend
everywhere in our hometown like when I'm
telling you you can't it's he's an
attorney it's a whole thing
she's a lawyer I knew awesome okay it's
like Detroit's uh Jacob call Jacob here
in L.A a tweet just went viral she put
up she based out of Dearborn but she put
a billboard in Lebanon now and so
someone posted no [__] way guys she's
here now too that's awesome
so you were close to royalty in a sense
yeah back if you could say that
we should get you a billboard in Lebanon
oh my God all right well that's some
[__] yeah and then the girl next to
her next to the winner
um I think she was like 31 at the time
can I open this
yeah dude there's the I got Lena's
permission oh my God bro they had a
swimsuit section of the Dearborn
holy crap they don't play around oh my
God yeah that to me
that's pretty rough man to go was that
awkward for you I guess that's part of
the game you're you're good at it yeah I
mean my family was there too and stuff
so
that's the game when
some people were asking how I saw photos
of her before I knew her it was
definitely The Talk of the Town for a
little bit that that pageant happened I
mean power to him I thought it was
awesome but yeah it was uh not all the
contestants were from Dearborn though
that's something that's another thing
too yeah wow it just was held there well
congratulations thank you
get her out there
so oh there's one thing I wanted to show
before the Tom Brady did you see the
thing I sent from the bathroom yeah we
put in the dock it's number 10. thank
you Elon Musk on Twitter get a load of
this guy
hi he's been talking about how he wants
to make Twitter the best place for
creators to post and earn money
he's so he goes
starting today Twitter will share ad
Revenue with creators for ads that
appear in their reply threads
cool
side note to be eligible the account
must be a subscriber to Twitter blue
verified so let me get this guy bro
because this sounds like a [__]
I don't this seems like some kind of
fraud is like to be eligible you have to
be okay 13 how much is it eight dollars
a month uh they increased it it's 11 now
oh he did so
so like
how is that sharing your Revenue you're
forcing people to pay you
probably because you don't have many ads
left like that's just so scummy
you have to pay us to be eligible to
make money
what yeah
it's crazy let's think of how to dig
ourselves out of this [__] man yeah I
guess that's one way
all right let's get to the uh the um
let's get to the facts of the Jeffree
Star business so Jeffree Star tweeted
this out okay
yeah goodbye La time to spend time with
my NFL Boo and Wyoming
now does Tom Brady have any association
with Wyoming
none whatsoever
I mean they're on a private jet I mean
this could be anybody
his team didn't make it to the Super
Bowl but he's 6-6 and plays perfect in
the bedroom so he's super whoever this
is is like really tall
he does kind of have a Tom brady-esque
do
oh he's wearing Louis Vuitton now
does Tom Brader braider braider is there
any pictures of him wearing this hoodie
no that's not his style man can I see
Tom Brady again to refresh my memory
yeah and we and we crunched the numbers
we try to determine the height and we
really got into the weeds with it Tom
Brady
he is uh
Tom Brady
that does look kind of like that hey I
do yeah yeah totally right
100 percent
and he just divorced from just
divorcedure yeah he didn't get in the
Super Bowl
he is just retired again how tall is he
he's six four okay he could be off
Jeffrey was guessing Jeffrey Jeffrey is
hyperbolic I bet well we got the facts
the show what the actual height is later
on so this is all pretty compelling
stuff Jeffrey continues oh my God now
the NFL wives are coming after me girl
don't be so insecure I don't mess with
married men
more uh baiting he's now divorced of
course I'm getting harassed because my
husband is in the NFL and people think
it's him please stop
that's a little bit of a I mean
silly silly DM yeah yeah
well who's her husband let's take a look
if her fears are valid yeah Henry
Anderson
I plays foreign Carolina Panthers
defensive
and
let's see if she's right if she's right
oh well yeah I guess I could see yeah
and how tall is he this guy seems wider
than the the guy in the picture though
right he seemed he's six six like a
bigger build I think yeah Tom Brady's
like more slender but this guy seems
thicker yeah
okay interesting that's Tom Brady ever
been with
uh anything other than women before like
you know dude I don't know until we hang
out Cam's ready like okay do you think
you can out throat goat um Jeffree Star
you're up against the the best
apparently you know I don't know I I've
never put it to the test in a
competition but I'm willing to throw
down for it
so you're interested in Tom Brady he's a
stud dude of course yeah I mean he is he
is I'm also a big fan of the Patriots
too so okay Tom Brady is a handsome guy
this is one of these guys he's got it
all it's just [__] outrageous it's
just oh the guy has won like 10 how many
Super Bowls has he won
Seven Spanish won seven super bowls and
he looks like this
and he's like
probably could have anybody he wants
right like he's so famous and just
divorced and no offense to Jeffree Star
but come on
thank you
just saying also how much is he worth
Tom Brady net worth I bet you he's like
a billionaire at this point
let's see
according to this random [__] he's
250 million I feel like he's worth more
than that Tom Brady such a stud he would
take uh contracts for the Patriots below
his weight uh below his uh worth because
he wanted the team to have more budget
players
what a guy
if he doesn't deserve a blowy I don't
know who does
that's right
okay so people are trying to crack the
case on this yeah
yeah so here let's take a look I'm bored
at work she said
in response to this picture
the spot is a mark from an IV so he's
likely a starter what does she report
what does that mean where's the IV spot
was this a video
spot is it on his right hand
it's on his right hand that there's a
little like Freckle on his vein
that little dot yeah oh okay yeah I
could see that
but that could be harder it's like a
main player they start you know okay you
know big names someone's right hand that
plus the legs being crossed to the left
I guess he's left-handed what does that
even mean Tom Brady's left-handed
famously right
uh I I don't think so actually hold on
let me look I think he is
but how do you even determine that from
the way somebody's legs are crossed you
know what I mean
no he is Left-Handed he's left-handed so
far a very good points in my opinion
case in point because I would oh sorry
he's right-handed I'm sorry oh wait wait
wait wait wait interesting little detail
okay I'm seeing he throws a football
right handed but when he played baseball
he batted left-handed so he handed both
ways you
I'm just saying
hey
ambidextric yeah okay yeah it seems that
he is was he Crossing his legs in an
ambidextrous way I don't know yeah
well they they continue I guess he's
left-handed the leg hair is very light
it's probably blonde or Ginger which he
was wrong about Jeffree star's six foot
and size 11 shoe so
I would guess he's slightly taller and
has a bigger foot six one six three and
since that is the Vans range the largest
size is 13. I would guess it's a 12 but
don't quote me on that let me dig into
the height well we saw a picture of them
together he is significantly taller than
Jeffrey and I just pulled up um you can
buy those shoes and size up to size 16
too so this is faulty yeah
from the photo I'm guessing it's
impressive though what this person did I
do appreciate the effort
from the photo I'm guessing this is a
next stance 400 XT which is a commonly
chartered
uh aircraft I'm guessing bottom layout
pick two see the porthole window and
recliner on the club
how does this help us
the club seat cushion oh my God the club
seat question is 24 inches in the lower
heel planted is three to four
the seat ends four to five feet from the
knee I would say his calf is 24 inches
approximately we can add average age of
NFL player 26 years and calculate height
from there 6.62.9
which you know means they list them at
six three that looks a lot skinnier calf
to me so we know uh Jeffree Star ain't
going for no linemen
skill position only
eliminate the married ones because it's
overnights the ones who are still
playing pro bowlers
the [__] does that mean like pro ball
players like it's the game before the
Super Bowl uh
sorry the thread was getting weird I
replied in good spots so oh God she's
doing calf check whoa
Bex and I think we have id'd the calf
sorry for the secrecy but only dicks out
people happy to tell you guys who it
isn't
Justin Herbert Aaron Rodgers Daniel
Jones probably anyone non-fl people
would know
PS took less than an hour fails we'll
always catch you
well she didn't say who she thinks it is
oh yeah why is that
interesting she wants somebody to like
really beg
for that okay well people are
professional she's not trying to you
know she's not trying to assert anything
that isn't airtight you know
hey uh M mask says hey me and my twin
sister just turned 30. been watching
forever Ela Kleiner forever thank you
for making our week so much better love
the crew love you thank you happy
birthday for allowing us yeah to serve
you
and Goblin in and out of goblin mode
so um
so well let's see your response let's
see where you guys got scientific with
it
okay should I open it or maybe uh do you
want to just send it to Ethan so he can
yeah I mean the Link's in the doc right
there what's in the dark yeah
this is the presentation right here all
right let's take a look
so we have our best and brightest in the
laboratory
trying to Crunch the numbers here not
that
slideshow
all right Thomas Edward Patrick Brady is
that his name yes it is well
[__] got too many goddamn names
his dad was also named Thomas Edward
Patrick Brady he's a junior
he's not banging Jeffree Star well
that's the conclusion well no there's a
whole no question this is just the intro
yeah this is the thesis exactly two
different pieces right
yeah wait we have dueling pieces yeah
all right there's no there's also a 50
bet going on in the office I bet Olivia
and Sam fifty dollars that it's not Tom
Brady come on I mean obviously it's you
you actually I thought it was obvious
but they took the bet they took that bet
I want it I think it could totally be
Tom Brady I'm willing it okay I wished
for it bro this is happening it's
happening all right let's watch so I'm
doing this for free too I'm doing this
for the love of the game so this is
Cam's argument that's not him this is
cam cam is saying no so Canon is comes
with some interesting facts he says
there's nothing new in 2021 the internet
lit up a speculating Kanye West and
Jeffree Star were banging I thought it
was hilarious star says I love rumors I
think they're funny but some girl on
Tick Tock made it up and went viral
before I even knew it
now what he is no stranger I was
thinking about that too that at this
point he's like playing that up so this
establishes two things one that he's
honest and two
that this has been a trend in the past
too that he was banging out recent
divorces
here we go this is not my fault repeat
this is not my fault I've never met Tom
but congratulations on retirement
Wyoming is a good place to retire he
says he's never met him yeah right but
didn't they say they were flying to
Wyoming together or was that a different
state those just well yeah it was but it
wasn't Tom Brady it was just a mystery
NFL player it was Tom Brady
well he said he's never met Tom he's
just establishing doubts why do you
think that yeah I don't I'm not with you
on this he's always telling the truth
business well I mean at least when it
comes to who he's
banging he's telling the truth here
because he said like he could have
easily leaned into the Kanye thing too
but he didn't okay no I think what
happened there was Tom was like Jeffrey
you're giving away a little bit too much
information
he needs to establish some doubt no he
immediately owned up to the fact that he
never had sex with me
everybody knows Wyoming is a beautiful
place to retire so
when he announced that he was retiring
and this was all happening I bet he was
like no no it's too much you need to say
you don't know me because everyone's
gonna know I'm gonna go to Wyoming so I
have a question Wyoming he's beautiful
he's probably like I just need a new
start I need to go ahead
so this Tom Brady tweet saying truly
grateful on this day thank you February
1st is that when the rumors came out is
he trying to prove he's not in Wyoming
no I believe that's just him announcing
his retirement he announced that he
retired totally okay this is unrelated
to this rumor yeah 28 million views this
is the greatest NFL player of all time
saying he's retiring okay
and Jeffree Star confirming that he's
never met him now let's analyze the
photo in question this is the one that's
really got people buzzing okay Tom Brady
6'4 Jeffree Star six one so he's very
tall that's actually interesting is this
three I mean that could be yeah that
could be three feet it also looks like
he's ending no he's re-entry or inches I
mean sorry that's way more than that
that's like a whole thing down a little
bit in that picture well I did a Justice
posture here to show ladies though okay
so so oh wow according to cam he used
the phone for reference
that Tom whoever's behind him is at
least 8.3 inches taller yeah
at least but then that would make him
like seven feet there's no NFL player
that tall no he would be six foot nine
so how many NFL players are that tall
that is not a quarter players are huge
that is plenty that is not a quarterback
all right that is on a quarterback's
body that's either a linebacker but he
looks skinny to me
nah that dude's bulky he's he's an
athlete but like the the
he looks like a quarterback to me he's
thin for an NFL player I don't think so
I think he's he's getting quarterback
he's defensive
no he's not on offense dude guys weigh
double that not linebackers linebackers
are like agile and [__] by the way
um about the height though some pictures
can just come out weird and it could be
like the way Jeffrey was standing I
agree he's closer to the camera than he
is oh he's closer to the camera then he
would be taller taller right okay so
you're opposite then From perspective
you're looking for
if what you're saying is right you're
looking for someone who is like insanely
[__] tall like 6 10. which I mean the
NFL does I mean I just found a website
these are all super tall NFL players
these are all people that are like six
eight or higher yeah average is six
sixty five so the 10 this guy I mean
they're up there freaks but hold on go
back to the main photo
we can both agree that's not a three
inch difference though no no way yeah no
way
hmm
but see I'm getting conflicting reports
on Jeffrey's height some people have
said he's six foot
you can't really his height you can't
rely on
you know like last year I was 510 for
the greater Clash this year I'm six foot
really yeah what the [__]
with athletes I'm sure obviously it's
more accurate because yeah yeah yeah I
think that based on
the information about Tom Brady's height
this is not him thank you I do think
Cameron makes a compelling Point here
though because as you can see the height
of this phone is 6.3 inches
and also Jeffree star's not standing up
straight yeah he is I adjusted him yeah
you'll see in the next I do want to say
when you Google Jeffree star's height it
says six one is like the pop-up thing
but the first result I just clicked on
this one's saying 511. I don't think
he's that I don't I think he's probably
five eleven or even five ten so maybe
we're not actually that confident on
that six one I there's no way Jeffree
Star 6-1 I don't believe it in fact can
we pull up a picture of Jeffrey starring
next to somebody else maybe yeah Shane
who we've seen we know Shane isn't super
tall we know that I've met him in person
he's probably he's not sure the same
height as me yeah I'd say five eleven or
something like that you know I I also
think Tom here is probably standing on
something maybe to throw people off
maybe his ass nah I mean his ass is on
the same level as his
you look at their waistline no I don't
know I think like it looks a little bit
oh he is taller well I don't know you
could be wearing shoes yeah you don't
know the full outfit he's definitely
wearing massive heels if they could have
told Tom to like stand on his tippy toes
for the photo that we don't know yeah we
don't know
yeah we don't know Zach you're on your
own with that one no look I'm getting a
lot of support in the chat on this one
that is a defensive player that is not
an offensive no one on offense that is a
linebacker or safety or something
whatever Tom Brady is that's what we
need that's what I see we need pictures
of Jeffrey where he's not all dolled up
because he's going without wearing heels
I'm gonna find a unicorn too while
you're at it yeah exactly well I don't
know something from one of his channels
or his documentary with Shane like a
candid one not like a always Dolla but
like a candid photo Okay so
um this one's interesting he does look
pretty tall
I think he's pretty tall
yeah the shoes we've seen Mike Mike's a
tall guy they call him Big Mike for a
reason but he's got to be wearing like
two or three inch heels
not always show me
Jeffree star's feet
buy me a picture
let me picture of his Footwear like a
full body picture yeah
like on a Runway or something there's
got to be a feet pick a Jeffree Star
somewhere uh
wikiFeet man a lot of people saying
Zach's right I don't I disagree dude the
defensive guys are way [__] bigger
than that dude that dude's huge
there you go
that's with the kind of shoe that
Jeffree Star walks around in now what's
that gonna add like two three inches I
mean that's massive and he could be
wearing he could be wearing those heels
in that photo too for the record
um yeah all right speculation he's not
come on Heels don't go with that outfit
you know the I don't know
all right well well I think
I think if we're gonna take this
it's not that big of a difference you're
saying he's at least eight inches taller
and the phone is six inches it's not
that big of a difference
I don't know this is just the show that
I okay you fixed his posture okay stand
up straight there
but you didn't move him up I did I mean
I guess the phone's covering it but
um
so January 30th not Tom's hair Yep this
is February 1st almost longer hair yeah
it's slightly more hit long there it's
not buzzed I'm not feathered look at the
sides the sides I will say this man's
hair looks thicker
hmm
because his there is kind of thin yeah
he's kind of holding on to those last
strands in the front
look how thick this guy's hair is on the
back
yeah doesn't hair
it recedes from the front yeah but you
would see it sticking out there from the
back too take it from me that's a full
head of hair we should ask Tom
get him on the phone but again again
it's not conclusive it's just it's not
enough
he also tweeted this photo of not Tom
whoops so he's posting his jacked
obviously
throat gone
dude
he's so wild for this
okay wow okay interesting AB check
they're not the same
okay I have a question
there's gonna be a big difference
between Tom Brady like postseason and
Tom Brady like because he just retired
he just got out of the season so he's
gonna have abs this is him when he
hasn't been playing I don't know man Tom
Brady is famously on the tb12 diet all
year round what's that this is like a
special diet diet the difference between
cam knows all the Lord you know what's
going on
this could be his idea this could be his
abs I don't think so it's a different
belly button
the belly button is different you think
he would
I don't know all this stuff could be so
like varying between one photo and
another exactly but do you think it
would be the belly button here is closed
here it's open but yeah could that be
the result of just like having ABS sure
posture sure I don't think it would
change it that much though that's like a
triangle belly button that Jeffrey's got
there okay it's it's it's it's
interesting but I don't think it's
conclusive if you think he was referring
to not Tom as the throat goat it's
referring to a beloved Pastime god-given
gift deepest of all time these are all
hyperlinks here that um there was some
talk around the office that they were he
could be calling Tom the not Tom the
throat goat but Jeffrey's himself the
throw coat right I think he's saying
he's the throat exactly yeah but they
were the Counterpoint was using that as
uh their evidence no I think he's he's
teasing because people call Tom Brady
the goat so he's like you're the goat
but I'm the throat oh okay well I guess
I didn't consider it yeah exactly okay
so Cameron makes puts for some
interesting hypothesis now Olivia let me
see yours yeah I'm not 100 sold
I do think you pulled out you did your
best with what you had yeah hold on
there is Mega awesome nerd just sent me
something very important here okay
breaking news thank you
look at the size of those shoes thank
you dude thank you Mega awesome dude you
this is what I'm talking about he looks
super tall in that photo look how fat
those heels are yeah that man five
eleven that's compelling okay maybe even
five ten okay so if that's the point
then then compare that to how tall the
other guy was still well if you add if
you take away a couple inches then it
lines up then it could be Brady was six
four
yeah six four yeah yeah and if Jeffrey
starts five ten okay five eleven five
eleven and we're talking six inches it
still looked like more than that to me I
don't know but it's hard to tell like
you said the perspective it's loud yeah
all right Olivia show us what you've got
perspective well here's the thing is
that was all the evidence presented it's
the feeling I think that's
yeah we don't have a PowerPoint
right now yeah yeah yeah backs don't
care about your feelings well you know
what is that really do I hope you have
more than that no I kept telling them
you know you better be ready to count it
but are you serious you guys don't have
any any this is the county we didn't
make a we didn't need to make a
PowerPoint why it's just the truth okay
so what do you guys have
is
we have to go he's he's really really
hinting at it when he says goat
that's what I've got we had you guys
really shouldn't be representing
yourselves in this court
this is why the judge really recommends
right but but we presented in a factual
way yeah judge Klein this council is way
out of line
okay I I have I understand I want to
submit I didn't want to ruin everyone's
fun but I just sent a tick tock I did
see this what is this what is this oh
there's wait if it looks really sadly
see this
wait so you wait there's a video you
were withholding it never figured it out
oh you guys were having fun you can made
a PowerPoint I'm not gonna ruin it no no
no no no no no no I was saying yeah
Olivia
tampering with evidence withholding
evidence from the opposing Council yeah
it's a literal crime yeah so he did not
submit this in Discovery this is way out
of line outrageous
objection the feeling okay you're you're
in contempt of court let's watch it and
Carl nassib's ex-boyfriend is gone he's
not on his Instagram anymore where'd all
the pictures go and this is a picture
without his shirt on it looks like he's
covering the tattoo on his arm and the
little moles on his stomach I could be
wrong but I think it's Carl I think we
got the
guy's hand was the same from the picture
on the airplane I don't know the build
looks like it yep and this is what he
was doing yesterday so what do you guys
think I'm feeling Carl that's my feeling
I'm feeling calm so you saw this yeah
you were still like I know I did say
something and someone was like let us
let us let us do it hold on hold on hold
on hold on but I figured it out this
picture and Carl nassib's ex-boyfriend
is gone Carl nassib's ex-boyfriend is
gone so this guy had a boyfriend he's
also he's also a gay man I object this
is why it's too easy
I think it's way too easy it's too easy
it's not true it's not right it's more
logical you want to see the back of his
head can you pull up yeah let me try and
find let me see some more photos dude I
gotta I got a shirtless pickup let me
kind of has a triangular belly button
one thing I will I would help Cam that
would help here's something I will
immediately say about this guy is he's
collecting bro he's got like a big fat
nap
cam just sent me a picture of Colton
Underwood oh what oh I just Googled okay
no I Google call NASA abs and that came
up that does not okay well shirtless
come on hold on wait did you really
think that was him
whoa right now I'm not looking at a
picture of of Colton okay
I gotta defend Cameron if you look up
Carl they literally look they look
somewhere they look pretty simple bro
you typed gay football no I typed in
Carl NASA
is so familiar to me Kim's whole
argument I mean come on I'm not looking
at the face
look Cam's exonerated let me talk abs
look at that here he is
all right so show me show me his hair
show me his hair that does not nothing
for me it's too short oh yeah that's too
short I don't know about the hairs it
does nothing I think Tom Brady pointing
out the neck I'd like to point out the
thickness of the neck here I'm not sold
on you don't see it on this guy
maybe he's been working out his neck
this is as this is all we get to throw
the people off yeah lost weight
this is all we get
it's Carl
I think so it's definitely not Tom Tom I
agree with you on that stuff somewhere
flashy Louis Vuitton no he doesn't I
have yeah exactly it's probably a gift
he's a model it was a gift from from
Louis Vuitton Jeffrey would give it to
him though that outfit is quick explain
the hair explain the hair I can't find
any pictures of this guy without hair as
long as in the picture with Jeffrey I
just I just want to point something out
what position is Carl Nassif a
[__] linebacker so that's
definitely not him he's a linebacker top
plates not him what are you talking it
is him that is the guy that is is the
same body type that is a linebacker
right there
no comment
yeah I mean there's a good shot
everybody's spamming the ears the ears
the ears what's up with the ears are red
that's the conclusion well how does that
happen well no it's just the light can
you zoom in on the ears can someone send
me a photo because every time I zoom in
it Scrolls to a different tick tock I
need like a photo of this of a
screenshot of this
I mean look it definitely there it
definitely is giving Carl Vibes yeah
who is a linebacker
and is Carl 66. I'll wear Brands like
Louis Vuitton you guys look
well I'm sure Jeffrey is draping him in
the finest uh silks yes exactly well no
Jeffrey does do that no but all these
guys are rich like they don't need no I
know he's rich but he literally has
Louis Vuitton symbols tattooed on his I
get that but
not really seeing anything about this
guy's style choices outside of but you
kind of agree that I have not seen his
hair this long on the top anywhere yeah
right that's what's throwing me is it
doesn't really look like his hair no it
did at first but when I look closely
it's like more gel too
I don't know golly every photo of this
guy his hair is way shorter than that
I'm not sure that it's him
I'm not totally convinced either it's
not Colton he's engaged
but it's also not Tom Brady there's no
way [__] it's Tom Brady yeah there's no
way in [__] dude well who else is it
then I don't know what to say he
literally told me where's the receipts
we need receipts for that okay wait how
tall is Carl did we fact check that uh
carlosib height is
it's a six seven but dude
hold on this is really [__] good baby
these ladies I don't know who they are
how tall they are but I get very short
Vibes that's also a top-down angle too
though also he's wearing heels this is a
short man Jeffree star's been lying
about his height there's no [__] way
to fix what or six one
this woman whoever she is looks like
five three
that
Jeffree star's five five bro
but she's bad short five seven she's
five seven with one inch heels so she's
five six five five but also you gotta
look at the angle of the camera it's
like this they're all affected by the
same angle dude yeah dang but it will
just mess everybody up it'll compress it
a little bit but I don't know is there
anything in the reflection
oh if there was you know people would it
I mean you saw that Twitter thread I
looked for it
they would have picked up on that quick
plus I don't know if TB would wear Louis
Vuitton if it was him that's what I
don't know him with Jeffrey I don't
think uh no Brady's got his own uh
athletic line which he always wears I
don't think he'd be wearing that why
would he be wearing
but you know he would wear like your
Boost clothes he put it on for the photo
flashy outfit wait and the pants nah Tom
Brady wouldn't wear that thank you thank
you we're not and he doesn't need the
free Louis Vuitton like whatever no
things are Ever Changing like style hold
on here is Tom Brady with a designer bag
interesting that is [__] interesting
that's a bag that's not an outfit
advised no but buying a bag is not
it looks like that [__] hair yeah but
it's not but I show you no but there's
no gel like that other guy I showed you
his hair is from no two days ago too
the point is is that he has shopped at
Louis Vuitton I understood but that does
not mean anything you could buy a bag
that's one step buying a full look like
that but also look at his pants and
Hoodie there isn't even a logo on there
but his shoulders are not as broad as
the one in the photo like if you look at
that yes I mean it's no way it's a Airy
jacket
um
I think you're I do see your point
though
but it's not that different dude who
took this were they like on the floor
like what the [__] like this angle is so
weird goat like step on me
but this was his hair you know just two
days ago Toms yeah I mean this lines up
no no no no not that one this one that's
from however long ago okay okay
yeah that hair looks very thin I don't
know how long ago this photo was but
that hair's struggling that was that was
literally two days ago I also don't
think that Tom Brady's haircut is that
kind wait a minute that guy's haircut is
a little bit more like douchey I just
noticed something you know what I mean
yeah I hear that is this a slight bald
spot here it's just a cow look that
hairstick but okay fair enough give me a
second
it's still an identifying trait I'm just
pointing it out I mean it right true
does Tom Brady have a palette that's
what I'm asking so I was just about to
say you said you think so I think so but
I mean not like that I Know Carl have a
cowlick
the Carl's hair
cowling you guys want to see some things
not everybody has one stop it what
look at Ethan's hair they do I do have a
little one but it's not noticeable
just a little square is it cowlick or
cowlick all right I have a cow
huge it's a cowlick cowlick what's a
cowlick how does a cowl lick what's a
cow lick I don't know you're the one
that said it I don't know what that is
if a cow licks the back of your head is
it a cowlick it's a cow with the harmful
it's not a cow it's cow what is a
cowlick cowl
c-a-l-l-i-c that that's not anything
[Laughter]
Tom Brady's bald spot on the back of his
head it looks thinner I'm just going to
tell you guys The Flash was on this man
has a thick [__] head of hair this
man that's not the same not the same Tom
Brady is more like Norm core his dad is
classy totally and this one is more like
Euro trash compared to Tom Brady right
wow heel is really smitten with yeah
with Tommy Boy
Cam and I are our first Bond was over a
love for Tom Brady he's a [__] stud
dude let's go for the Boston accent come
out anytime he talks about Tom Brady
he's a [__] God I [__] love him it
looks like it looks like he's treating
Jeffrey super super well so it's not Tom
Brady sorry girls I'm happy for them
it's it's not Tom we need to pull though
and I really had to open mind here
I really want at first I thought that it
is him from the back we can do a poll
yeah so do you think because we asked
right before and it was about 40 60. we
should just say is it Tom Brady yes or
no we don't even need to speculate as a
Carl use your heart no use your heart
there we go use your heart the thing is
it looks so much like his silhouette
though it does yeah he's way too big
that's a big boy
why would you even say that about Tom
Brady he's monsters Tom Brady's a
perfect uh proportion he's not as a
gargantuan offensive like I don't well
uh fortunately ladies not preparing a
PowerPoint has it's hurt the case hurt
the case Big Time 77 say no to be frank
when we were trying to pull evidence it
only worked against us
it was just the same evidence
judge Klein I would like to uh propose
their disbarment
thank you
wow
well that was a kind of a fun Journey
yeah I like the investigative honestly I
was I was sweating bullets all morning
because I was thinking they were gonna
pull out like my cousin Vinnie
um
I thought you guys had crazy great
surprise witness the heart wants what
the heart wants and I want Tom Brady but
I don't that wasn't him well the good
news is Cam that he's still on the
market yeah that's right he's still a
single agent or however you call it free
agent reagent yeah
actually we're probably been going for a
while but there's a few things I want to
hit
yeah we haven't talked about keemstar in
a while just remember the fourth hour
curse
fourth hour curse well how far we've
been going yeah we started late today
we've been going about uh 2 40. I'm not
going up on three hour mode
well you are because 240 that's like 20
minutes away the analogy is this
I'm I'm the airplane that Just Got
Hijacked and it's flying towards the
World Trade Center I'm about like
three-fourths the way there Goblin mode
is when the plane hits the building
uh-huh there's still time
if only
only they know
um
yeah we got 20 minutes everybody 20
minutes I just I love this keemstar
stuff because it's so funny he's such a
[__] loser I mean I haven't talked
about him in a while just because I'm
drunk he's basically fell off the edge
of the planet yeah and um but he was
going wild on his show he started the
show what he does from his uh basement
bar
by himself
as far as I can tell maybe sometimes he
does it with the
Brantley Brantley comes on the stream
later on this is like a several hour
stream but check this out just enjoy
this 19 second clip okay you guys are
gonna love this
when you go below 16 like 15 and stuff
like that that you know by all means
right but 16 is the age of consent and a
lot of states in America and and
Australia and [__] the United Kingdom
throughout Europe you know what I mean
it's like it's not that bad when you go
below 16 like 15 and stuff like that
this [__] this guy recorded that
[__] and put it online I mean there's
nothing left to cancel he's been like
basically demolished but wow this is uh
some crazy [__]
content
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's pretty
wild uh can you can we pull out
chestnuts for this please
when you go below 16 like 15 and stuff
like that that you know by all means
states in America in Australia
[Music]
Europe you know what I mean it's like
building Tower one has been hit can you
go below 16 like 15 or something like
that that you know by all means
States stop
oh my God
it's pretty wild eh groom stuff baby I
love you
I just especially when he's dating a
young girl and he's talking about I just
met this high school girl is so hot play
that again Zach
yo bro I'm at this high school girl that
I was hot as [__] tonight
you add all that up I I get a picture of
a dude who's trying to [__] like uh a 16
year old yeah
acoustic
That's crazy dude
so there that is that I loved that clip
and I wanted to share it with y'all
prime plus bro you should he should be
barred from touching a woman again after
he said that and I'm like [__]
bumping
prime plus what the [__] is that one
that's when he's at the club I need a
jewel punch
with the acoustic uh wrap set acoustic
acoustic acoustic oh this is funny so as
soon as he said that by the way
his chat started turning on him
check this out yeah I wonder why imma
head out unsub on sub unsub
s
[__] is this
even dance singing now
here it goes uh no he's done what the
question mark question mark oh hell no
dog and you know keemstar probably has
all degeneracy like who the [__]
watching keemstar
Al keemstar
he's an adult running off a Discord full
of kids came what question mark question
mark team not bro don't say that
pedophile he's made his own audience
uncomfortable L Keem L Keem
you know Keem what are you waffling
about elk star
it just keeps going crazy this one dude
agrees facts King this one
we gotta we gotta link up he's spitting
so uh yeah that's crazy he's trying to
run defer defense for himself saying
that like he was talking about
is that even true Maybe
I don't know yeah I believe so yeah but
I don't really think that matters eh
I mean his chat turned on him yeah
side note is
oh this is also interesting you know
what let's not even show this one
that's it it's just like a fun little
thing for you guys
other than that we've got a mascara gate
update oh what's the update you want
that one
all right we should wrap it up after
Miss irrigate then just quickly also
this one is super interesting
this 23 year old is dating
as 26 year old
however because of some kind of
genetic disease I don't know exactly she
has a growth stunted growth oh this is
actually super sad just stunted growth
due to treatment received as a child for
brain cancer
she looks like she's eight yeah
so I just thought it was kind of an
interesting uh
conversation to have where it's like
well obviously she's an adult but she
deserves maturity is like an adult right
yeah yeah I mean no she's 26. yeah
but but it's got to be hard to go out in
public that's just going to be weird as
[__]
you know her face she's just really
small I don't know God I don't know yeah
holy [__] no I don't know it's hard to
say she does look like really young but
obviously she deserves to uh as an adult
to find love and have romantic
relationships yeah
I don't know does anyone have any
thoughts on this
seeing the chat uh I guess knows about
I've never heard of this wait she's on a
TLC show oh
she's 50 pounds three foot ten inches
oh this is like a okay of course TLC is
all over this
they aren't dating he made a statement
says somebody oh they are not uh random
chatter says that I mean I don't know
okay okay
she acts very immature well that's that
would be my question it's more about
like is she actually mature well she's
26 either way
I understand that but okay well I guess
this is out of my depths because I love
the show we know enough yeah bad info
we're moving on
so let's say uh okay this is the last
one uh the mascara gate
so after a full week of Silence Michaela
the my the mascara gay girl
returned to tick tock to address mascara
gate
in her return
she began the video by saying well I
think we all know why we're gathered
here check this out here she is
laughs
I'm sure we all know why we've all
gathered here today why is she talking
like that
anyone who knows me knows I'm not
[__] around hairy [__] Fisher
wait it's the month which is she sounds
like Carrie Fisher I can't totally it's
wild
well so she used this as an opportunity
to promote something else
nothing yeah many of the fans were
prepared to hear the explanation however
she did a four-part
just Valentine's Day makeup so she
didn't even acknowledge it someone
um someone commented are you going to
talk about the elephant in the room and
she says I reference elephants in this
video and she doesn't like reference
mascara gate at all talk about the
allegations so she's she's skirting
around it I mean in a way like this is
probably the best thing she can do
that's what that's what um people online
are saying it's like just move on
because what is there to say yeah you
know it's just it's like it's just a
dumb thing she didn't like harm anyone
necessarily so I would just try to I
would if I was look if I was hurt this
would never happen
I just
last Friday right the day that I was out
so just to remind me this was
it was like a sponsored post about some
mascara or something yes and she claimed
she wasn't wearing any it was a moment
where people are sure that she put on
fake fakeies as they're showing the
after of this
era
and it was like a big brand it was like
L'Oreal right okay I remember yeah I
remember looking yeah it's the ads is
the video still up there yes it is wow
not backing down
and oh my God another Vaseline I've got
a Vaseline bestie
I thought I was looking in the mirror
for a second
dude that's wild I'm sorry I don't care
I I couldn't do you really do that you
rub Vaseline all over your face some
people use a bump to take off their
makeup oh oh bomb yeah I just sent um in
chat screenshot of some of the comments
bomb them
Bob
here's some of the comments let's take a
look
sorry Eli cut you off a minute ago
you don't remember no no
now Mick you know what you did there in
the beginning well obviously she's back
and unbothered love to see it uh I guess
people don't care yeah it's not a big
deal yeah I mean
faking that kind of stuff in like a
makeup commercial I mean is that not
every single commercial ever like I know
it's different because it's an
influencer I guess it's supposed to feel
I think for other Beauty influencers and
I'm only gonna guess here I think it's
like a big problem because they are very
truthful understanding right and she's
not here I guess that's fair because I
just think of like seeing like fraud
it's false advertising too but L'Oreal
right but like is it not when they have
a TV commercial that's on during the
Nightly News and it's like
you know supposedly somebody using the
product but you know on a commercial
it's all fake no I I think that they
probably do have to use the product or
they're beautiful I mean I think they'll
have like the best people in the world
to make it look as good as possible I
guess I'm sure eyelashes and commercials
but with specifically to influencers
it's their job to be honest exactly you
know how long you know how tech tech
influencers have a lot of like rules
sure amongst themselves yeah for their
credibility so I'm assuming it's the
same for the beauty that makes total
sense yeah what is this
likes by Jeffree Star like by Jeffree
Star that does look like him Carl and
Steve's Instagram Jeffrey who it is
that's the guy Carl the other football
player
but Jeffree Star can like anyone's photo
exactly right but it does look like him
does look like it could be him that's
the Carl guy yeah okay he looks a lot
less like built there because that was
what was throwing me is the guy in
Jeffrey's photos didn't look like like
that in the football photos of that
guy's neck is like a tree trunk and it
didn't really look like the guy in
Jeffrey's photos such a blast from the
past that's cheese just pulled that one
out all right guys listen I'm gonna I'm
gonna call it a day here oh I gotta
thank some folks with some gifties
gifties is that in the the chattering uh
it was it's been getting buried I can
shout out uh some of the bigger ones
Yeah Yeah from the last few minutes
though yeah a little spreadsheet here
thank you Sophie Elena for the gifties
that's awesome 30 gifties from you dirty
Nick mower 10 gifty thank you so much
God bless yeah this Tuesday we're gonna
have a see you next Tuesday as always
it's gonna be fun uh to get together
with you guys all and we have uh we have
a pretty fun guest next Monday
we have the therapy gecko Lyle I'll be
back for another round yeah so uh we'll
um be opening it up to some uh advice
calls like we did last time and uh
having some fun with that that will be
fun yeah
and I think there's something else fun
coming up next week too oh Friday is uh
idubbz and Anissa yeah that Creator yeah
coming up Fast Five sure yeah you
feeling good yeah feeling good nice
excited to get it over with yeah how's
your stamina it's it's getting in there
is it better than it was yeah definitely
I was watching old footage yesterday
I was cringing hard I definitely got a
lot better since last year so all right
that's exciting nice nice
you got to beat dad's ass bro for all of
us
by the way uh if I could just say happy
birthday it's his birthday today happy
birthday
gonna be your last we'll be nice then
yeah no happy Birthday Dad he needs to
be humbled especially on his birthday
how old is he now 54 uh old as [__] uh
four around there 42. he's actually four
oh he's here
he's a lot older than me that's crazy
all right see you guys later happy
birthday happy birthday Ethan
foreign
[Music]